the course you are about to watch is
about pointers in c
the course was developed by the
excellent instructors from
my code school my code school is one of
the earliest software channels on
youtube
and has inspired many developers and
creators in the description i've
included a link to an article about the
channel's amazing story
now let's get to the course pointer
is a very fundamental and important
concept in programming
but a lot of beginner programmers find
it difficult to understand pointers
so in this lesson we will try to
demystify pointers
and all you need to know to understand
this lesson is
how to write a basic c program how to
declare a variable
and how to do simple arithmetic upon
those variables
okay so let's get started to understand
pointers
we first should understand how
various data types or various variables
are stored in computers memory
okay so let us say this figure in the
right here
is computers memory and when we talk
about computers memory in context of
program execution we mostly talk about
the random access memory or the ram
we often say that my machine has got 2
gb of 2 gigabytes of ram
or 4 gigabyte of ram now let's say these
segments
or partitions that we are showing here
in the memory is each
one byte of memory now in a typical
memory architecture in a typical
computer architecture of the memory
each byte of the memory has an
address so let's say
the first byte in this memory which we
can assume to be
the lowest by deep down here has an
address zero and the address keeps on
increasing as we go towards the top
so we go on like zero one two and let's
assume
this particular address is
two zero one so the next byte would have
an address of
two zero two and we will go on like two
zero three two zero four and so on
now when we declare a variable in our
program let's say
for example if we declare a variable a
of type integer
then when this program executes the
computer allocates
some amount of memory corresponding to
this particular variable
how much memory it allocates depends
upon
the data type and also upon
the compiler so in a typical modern day
compiler an integer
is allocated 4 bytes of memory character
variable
is allocated one byte of memory
float is allocated four bytes of memory
and we can have
other variables as well okay so as soon
as the computer sees a declaration
like this during the program's execution
it knows that this is an integer
variable so we i need to allocate
4 bytes of memory let's say in our
example it allocates
memory starting address 204 to address
207
for a and the computer has an internal
structure
a lookup table where it stores this
information that there is a variable a
it is of type integer and it is located
at address 204
which is the starting address of the
variable now
if we declare another variable say for
example if we declare a variable named c
which is of type character now once
again when the machine sees this
declaration
it knows that it is a character variable
so it needs one byte of memory
so it looks for some free space let's
say in this case
it allocates the address 209 the byte
209 for c and once again
it keeps an entry for it in an internal
structure
called lookup table that is c is a
character
and its address is 209. now when we
perform some operation
with these variables like let's say if
we initialize a to 5
when our machine or computer sees such a
statement
it looks into the lookup table for this
variable a
so it finds this variable a that it is
an integer and
it is at address 204 so
it goes at address 204 and in these four
bytes
starting 204 it writes this value
5. now in reality the value is written
in binary but
for the sake of understanding we are
writing here in decimal form
now once again let's say we have some
statements and then again after these
statements we
have another statement which increments
a now again
when computer sees that a has to be
incremented it again looks for this
address for a goes to the address and
modifies this
value at this particular address so this
block of memory allocated for a
stores the value 6 now now all of this
is really cool but
can we know the address of a variable
in our program or can we operate upon
these memory addresses in our program
well yes you can do so in a c or c plus
program using the concept of pointers
pointers are variables that store the
address of another variable
and to make you understand about this a
little better i'll redraw a couple of
these things
let us say we have a block of four bytes
at address 204 that stores an integer
variable
a now we can have another variable
the type of which is pointer to integer
and let us say the name of this variable
is p
now this variable p can store the
address of
a and using the properties of
p or using some operators upon p
we can reach a now p also takes
some memory so let's say it is stored
at location address 64 and it also takes
4 bytes of memory
we can also modify p to point to
another integer so let's say if we have
another integer at address208
named b and having value 10 and if we
change the address in p
from 204 to 208 then p
now points to b let us now see
the syntax of pointer variables and see
a normal variable
is declared by writing the data type
and the variable name so int a means
that we have a variable a
of type int if we want to write a
pointer variable that should
point to another variable all we do is
we
put an asterisk sign before the variable
so p is now
a pointer variable that points to an
integer
so p is a variable that can store the
address of an integer
now to store the address of a
in p we need to use a statement like
p is equal to ampersand a
now if we put ampersand in front of a
variable
it gives us the address of that
particular variable in fact it returns a
pointer
to that particular variable okay so
let's try to see a simulation of this
let's say when we declared the variable
a then it was allocated an address 204
now we declare an a pointer to
integer p let's say it was allocated at
a 64.
now when we write a statement like p is
equal to ampersand a
then p now has the address of a
and it kind of points to a
let's initialize a to some value let's
say a is equal
to 5 so we fill value 5 into a now
now what will happen if i print b what
will be the output
any guesses think about it
okay so if we try to print p then
the output will be 2 0 4 because p has a
value 2 0 4.
what if we simply try to print ampersand
of a
ampersand of a also gives us the address
of a so this will also be 204
what if we want to print ampersand of
p now p is also a variable and it is
also stored in the memory
so ampersand since it prints the it
gives you the address of that variable
so printing ampersand of p should give
us
64 which is the address of p now there
is one more important property of
pointer
if we put an asterisk sign in front of
the pointer
then it gives us the value at the
location that it points to
so what will happen if we try to print
star of p
as trick of p well it will give us
5 this concept is called as
dereferencing
because we have a reference or we have
stored the
an address in p and we kind of get the
value at this particular address using
this operator
in fact we can modify the value at this
particular location
by saying something like star p is now
eight star p means value at p
and so the value at p is now modified to
eight
so what will happen if you print star p
or print a now
the output will be eight
by value of p i mean value at address p
so p is the address and star p is the
value
at address that is stored in p okay to
just to reiterate uh we define a pointer
variable
using by putting an asterisk sign in
front of the variable name
and if we put an ampersand sign in front
of a variable name we get the address of
it
so if we try to print a pointer variable
without asterisk sign or operate upon it
without asterisk sign we are operating
with the address
while if we put an asterisk sign in
front of the pointer variable
and operate upon it then we are
operating the value at that address
so this was some of the basics of
pointers in the coming lessons we will
some
see some code snippets where we will see
some of the common errors that we make
while using pointers and we will also
learn pointer arithmetic
and pointers in the context of arrays so
thanks for watching
so in our previous lesson introduction
to pointers
we learned the basics of pointers in
this lesson we will see how to work with
pointers
in some real code examples but before
that
a quick recap pointers are variables
that store
address of other variables we declare a
normal
normal variable with a syntax like
the data type or the variable type
followed by
the variable name but we declare a
pointer variable
with a syntax data type and
an asterisk sign followed by the
variable name
we need an integer pointer variable to
store the address of an integer
to store the address of say a character
variable we will need
a character pointer so the same syntax
will be used we put an asterisk sign
and let's say the name of the variable
is p0
so c is a character variable and p
naught is a
pointer to character and similarly we
can have a pointer
to double and we can also have pointers
to a user defined structure or a user
defined
class also and to get the address of a
variable
we write a statement like p is equal to
ampersand
a now this ampersand works as an
operator that gives us the address of a
and what happens in the memory is
something like this
variable p stores the address of
variable a
so in this figure here b's value is 2 0
4 which is the address of a
so p points to a and using p
we can also get the value of a
so let's say if a is 8 and we
use a star operator in front of p then
the star b gives us
8 which is value of a if we try to print
star b
it gives us 8. let us now try to see
some of these
in real code okay so time to see things
moving in a real c program
now what i'll do is i'll play a game
with you i will write some print
statements and you need to guess
what will be the output so what i'll
first do is i'll declare an
integer variable a and then i'll declare
another variable which will be
pointer to integer and now i'll write a
print statement
where i'll be printing p now
what will be the output of this program
okay so let's run this program
oops this gives us an error and if it is
too small for you to read
then this is giving an error that the
variable p
is not initialized and we are using it
without initializing so that's why the
program is crashing
so now i will write a statement p is
equal to ampersand
a now ampersand of a is
nothing but address of a now let's
run this again okay so this prints
an address and how do we know that this
is the address
or this is the right address that is
stored in p
so i'll write another print statement
and now
i am printing star p now star operator
when it is
put in front of the address then it
gives us the value at that particular
address
okay so what will be the output of the
second print statement
so when we run this the the first line
gives us the address that p
points to and this address is different
than the previous address because
every time the program runs afresh
new addresses are located but the value
at p
is some garbage value is some integer
that i'm not sure what it is
this is happening because i have not
initialized a
and although memory is allocated for a
there is
some garbage value there that i do not
know about okay so let's initialize a
let's say
a is equal to 10 and now the second line
prints the value of a
and now i will write another print
statement
and this time i'll print ampersand
a now what should be the output of
this third print statement and this
should be pretty easy to guess
ampersand operator gives us the address
and that's why
the third line is also the address of a
in fact that's what we have done here
when we have assigned p
the address of a we have used the
operator ampersand
now what i will do is i will modify the
value in
a using the pointer p and to do so i
will write a statement like
star p is equal to 12 and this is read
as
value at address p value at address
being pointed by p
is now 12. this concept is called d
referencing
so now if i try to print a
and let's also put one print statement
for a
before we modify the value and let's
run this so the first print gives me 10
which is the value that we had
initialized a with
and the second print gives us a
is equal to 12 because we modified the
value
using the pointer okay so one more thing
that i'll do here now
i'll have another variable b that will
have value 20
and now what i'll say is star p
or value at address p is equal to b
and the question now is that will the
address in p
change now to point to b well
no unless you explicitly write a
statement like
p is equal to ampersand b this reverse
operation will not happen what we are
doing here is actually only
putting in the address of a the value
that b
has but we are not pointing to b and
this will get clear
only if we write some more printf
statements
so before writing the statement i'm
writing two print statements
one to print the address and one to
print the value
and after we write the statement i'll
write two more print statements
trying to print the address and value
again so let us see what the output is
now
okay so address of p initially is three
one four four five seven six
and value is ten and after this
statement star p is equal to b
only the value is modified and the
pointer still points to a
so a kind of now becomes 20 but the
address does not change
now one more thing sometimes we declare
and initialize a variable in the same
statement
so instead of writing this a equal 10
here we could simply say
that int a is equal to 10
so we can do so for the pointer variable
as well we could simply say
for these two statements one simple
statement like in star
p is equal to ampersand a
and we will not need the statement this
one statement is same as saying the
earlier two statements
the syntax of declaring pointers some
people
write this asterisk sign after end and
do not write it
in front of the variable name this also
works and this is also fine
so you can write in star which is which
means pointer to integer and then you
can write the variable name
and this will also work okay so now we
will point
we will talk about a concept
we will talk about the concept of
pointer arithmetic
but before that i'll write this rewrite
this
declaration and initialization like
before in two statements
i like it better this way it's less
confusing now i will write two print
statements here
in the first statement i'll print p and
in another statement
i will print p plus 1 now is it really
possible to do so
can we really increment and decrement a
pointer variable
well yes we can do so so now let's
assume
that the address stored in p is
something like two zero zero two so any
guesses what p
plus one will be will it be two zero
zero three
well no p plus one will be two zero 2006
this is because if p is an integer
pointer incrementing it
by one unit takes us to the address of
the next integer
and because the size of an integer is 4
bytes
so to go to the next integer address we
need to skip four bytes so
b plus one increments p by
four bytes i'll write another print
statement in which i'll print
the size of an integer variable and i'll
write something like size of
integer is and we have a function in
c size off that gives us the size of a
data type
so this statement this print statement
will give us the size of integer
and let's write in the first and third
print statement something like
address p is blah and address p plus one
is blah so let's now run this and see
what happens
okay so the output is address p is four
five eight six
zero five two which is some address and
then
we print size of integer is four bytes
so for this particular compiler
the size of an integer is four bytes and
address p plus one
is 4 bytes more than address p you can
try this thing out for
a character pointer or a double pointer
or a pointer of some other data type
okay so we could also increment this by
2 and
what happens if we increment this by 2
well it will
increment the address by 8 so
this will be like 2 0 1 0
p plus 2 will be 2 0 1 0 and this 2 0 0
2 and 2 0 1 0 is
something that i've picked up randomly
just for the sake of example
okay so now once again what if i want to
print the value at this particular
address
so i'm printing two more lines here now
i'm printing that value at address p
is and i'll print star p which gives us
the value at that address
and we will print another line where
we'll say that value at address p
plus 1 is and this should be star
p plus 1 we put the star operator in
front of the address
okay so now what will be the output okay
so the output is that
address p is some address and value at
address p is 10 which is all right
because we had stored the address of
variable
a in p now next line is size of integer
is 4 bytes and p plus 1 is 4
more than the address p and the value at
address p
plus 1 is some integer value that i do
not know about
in fact this is some garbage value
because because
we do not really have an integer
allocated to this particular memory
address
and this is one dangerous thing about c
using pointer arithmetic using pointer
manipulation you can reach
to any address and sometimes these kind
of operations can bring some unwanted
behavior to your program
i recommend trying these things out
these snippet of code with
other data types like character or float
and the result
results will be similar so this was
some playing around with pointers and
in the coming lessons we will talk more
about pointers and we will talk about
pointers in the context of
arrays so thanks for watching
so far in our previous lessons we have
seen how to work with pointer variables
so we pretty much understand the basics
in this lesson we will write some more
code using pointers
and we will look through some of these
concepts
in more detail using some examples the
first thing that i want to point out
is that pointer variables are strongly
typed
what it means is that you need a pointer
variable of a particular type to store
the address of a particular
type of variable so instar or a pointer
to integer will be needed to store the
address of an integer
character pointer will be needed to
store the address of a character
and similarly if we have a user defined
structure or
class then we need a pointer of that
particular type only
but why do we need these strong types
isn't it that the pointer variables just
store the address of the variable so why
couldn't we have just one type
that will be some generic type to store
the address
of all kind of variables and the answer
is that we do not use the pointer
variables only to store memory addresses
but we also use them
to de-reference these addresses so that
we can
access and modify the values in these
addresses
now as we know data types have different
sizes
like in a typical modern day compiler an
integer
it's stored in four bytes a character
variable
is stored in one byte a float
is again stored in four bytes and these
variables differ not only
in their sizes they also differ in how
we store
information in whatever bytes are
available for these
variables or data types let's say we
have an integer
a and its value is one zero two five and
this
is how it is laid out in the memory each
each bracket here is one byte so let's
say this particular byte which is the
least significant byte
is byte 0 and then we go on like byte 1
byte 2 and byte 3 now we also know that
each byte in the memory is addressable
let's say the address of byte 0
is 200 now these four bytes need to be
contiguous let's say the address of byte
2 byte 1 is 2 0 1 and then we go on like
2 0 2 and 2 0
3 when an integer is represented in the
memory
is stored in the memory the leftmost bit
stores the information that whether this
integer is positive or negative so this
is also called
signed bit sign bit and rest 31 bits are
used to store the value
so if you see we have a 1 at right most
bit with place value 2 to the power 0
and at this particular bit with place
value
2 to the power 10 so the overall value
that we have in binary here
is 1 0 2 5 in decimal
now what if i declare a pointer to
integer
p and store the address of a in p by
using the ampersand operator
what will happen if i print the value of
p the value of p
or the address stored in p will be 2 0 0
the address of byte 0 so we are kind of
saying that
we have the address of an integer
variable starting at address 2 0 0.
if we dereference this address and try
to print asterisk p
we want to know the value at this
particular address then the machine sees
that okay p
is a pointer to integer so we need to
look at
4 bytes starting address 2 0 0
and then the machine knows that how to
extract
extract the value of an integer data
type
so it retrieve it retrieves the value
one zero two five
out of these four bytes now if p was
a character pointer then while d
referencing the machine would have
looked at only one byte because a
character variable
is only one byte if p was a pointer to
float
then although float is also stored in
four bytes but the way
information is written for float in
these four bytes is different
from the way information is written for
an integer data type
so the value printed would have been
something else let's go write some of
this in a real program
and see what happens in my c program
i'll first declare an integer a
equal to one zero two five and now i'll
declare a pointer to integer
p and then i'll store the address of
a in p by using the ampersand operator
now i'll write a print statement
like this size of integer
is and we have a function size off and c
which gives us the size of a particular
data type in bytes
and now i'll write a print statement
like this address is equal to
p and value is equal to
asterisk p with d reference p to print
the
value now let us see what is the output
of this program
no points for guessing this is pretty
straightforward the size of integer
is 4 bytes the address that we are
showing here is sum address
and the value is one zero two five
okay now i'll do some trick here i'll
declare a character pointer let's say
the name of the variable is p0
now i'll try to put the same address
as we have in p into p0 by writing a
statement like this
but this will give us a compilation
error because p0
is a pointer to character and p is a
pointer to integer
so what we will do here is we'll type
cast
p to character pointer
and then assign the value and now i'll
write two more print statements
first size of character is these many
bytes and we use the method size of
again
and the second is the address is p0 and
the value at address is
asterisk p0 so vd reference we try to
dereference p0 now
and let us see what's the output now the
first line of output is size of integer
is 4 bytes
address because we are running the
program fresh
this address will not be the previous
address the address from the previous
run
this will be a different address by
dereferencing the integer pointer we are
getting the value one zero two five
now the next line of output is size of
character is one bytes
address is five three seven three zero
three two which is the same address
as we have in the second line but the
value this time
is 1 now why is this value 1
once again if we write 1 0 2 5 in binary
using 32 bits
then this will be the representation
when we do this
type casting here trying to store the
address of p
in p0 then the address of this
particular byte
the right most byte is stored in p0
but when we de-reference p0 because p0
is a pointer to character the machine
says that hey this is a pointer to a
character
and the character is only one byte so i
look at only one byte to see the value
and if you see this particular byte in
binary
is one and that's why this output here
is one
okay i'll write two more print
statements now
one to print the address p plus one and
the value at address p
plus one now as we know we can add or
subtract
an integer constant from a pointer
variable
this is allowed in fact the only pointer
arithmetic that is allowed is adding or
subtracting some constant integer value
to the pointer p plus 1 will take us to
the address of the next integer
so it will skip 4 bytes and take us 4
bytes ahead
let's say we also want to print p 0 plus
1 and the value at p 0 plus 1
ok now let's see the output of this
particular program
the address of a this time is 4 4 six
zero three six
that's what is allocated for a in this
particular run
the value is one zero two five p plus
one is four four five six
zero four zero if you see this is four
bytes more than
the address of a because size of integer
is 4 bytes and p
is a pointer to integer so incrementing
b takes us 4 bytes forward
and this value is some garbage value
because we have not filled anything in
this particular address
so there is some garbage in the memory
which we are picking up
now the address in p 0 is also 4 4 5 6 0
3 6 which is the address of the
first byte the least significant byte of
a
the value is 1 now p zero plus one is
four four five six zero three seven here
we have
a value which is one byte more and this
is because character
is stored in one bytes now the value
here is four
if you see p zero plus one will take us
to this particular byte the address of
this particular byte
and this particular byte in binary is
4. this was to show you how things
happen in memory when we de-reference a
pointer variable by using the asterisk
operator
and also what happens when we perform
pointer arithmetic
with a particular pointer type this type
casting of pointer variable from one to
another
also has some use cases we will discuss
them later
now we will discuss one pointer type
which is generic pointer type
it does not correspond to a particular
data type and this pointer type is
called void pointer
and we declare this particular pointer
type by using the keyword
void and using an astrix sign in front
of the variable name
okay now we can write something like p0
is equal to p we do not need an explicit
type casting here
like this the statement p 0 is equal to
p
is valid and this will not give you
compilation error
and because this particular pointer type
is not mapped to a particular data type
we cannot de-reference this particular
pointer variable so if you try to print
star
p naught or asterisk p naught this will
give you
an error we are getting a compilation
error
we can only print the address and as we
can see here the address is same as the
address of
a and if we perform arithmetic
if we try to uh do something like p0
plus one access something like p0 plus
one
this is also not possible this will also
give you compilation error
we will come back to the use cases of
void pointers
in forthcoming lessons let's for now
know that there is something called void
pointers
so this was diving deep into pointer
types
and pointer arithmetic we will have a
lot of fun with pointers in the coming
lessons
so thanks for watching in our lesson
so far we have seen how we can work with
pointers
in some of the basic scenarios but there
are some scenarios
where pointers can be really puzzling
and
one such scenario is when we want to use
pointers to pointers
so in this lesson we are going to see
how we can use
a pointer to pointer let us assume that
this
is a logical view of computers memory
and
each partition here is one byte of
memory now we know that
each byte of memory has an address we
have drawn the memory horizontally here
let us assume that the address increases
as we go from left to right
so if this byte is at address 200 the
next byte would be at address 201
and the next byte would be at address
202 and so on
now let's say in my program i have
declared
an integer variable named x
and maybe i have initialized it
as and now when the program will run
some amount of memory will be
allocated for this variable x in a
typical architecture
in a typical compiler integer is stored
in
four bytes so four byte will be
allocated for x so
let's say these 4 bytes at address 225
this block of 4 bytes starting address
225 is allocated for x
and the value stored in this block of 4
bytes for
x is 5. now the next thing that i want
to do is
i want to declare a pointer variable
that will store the address of x now to
store the address of an integer we will
have to declare a pointer to integer
something like this we need to put an
asterisk sign in front of the variable
name
now what will happen is that some amount
of memory will be reserved for this
variable
p in a typical architecture pointer is
also stored
in 4 bytes so let's say we get this
block of 4 bytes at address 215
for p and now i want to write a
statement like this so i want to fill in
the address of
x in p and that's how p
points to x ampersand operator gives us
the
address of a variable now one important
thing here
we are able to store the address of x in
p because
p is of type pointer to integer
if p was of type pointer to character
or pointer to some other variable this
statement
p equal ampersand x would not have been
valid
so if i have to write down the types of
these two variables
then x is an integer and p
is pointer to integer or i can also say
that that
p is in star or asterisk
and y pointer variables are strongly
typed
why do we need a pointer to integer to
reference
or store the address of an integer it is
because
we don't just store the address of a
variable in a pointer variable
we also use the pointer variable to
dereference the address and write some
value there so if i write a statement
like this
this value here at address 225 and this
x is now modified now can i create a
pointer to this variable
p which itself is a pointer to integer
well yes we actually we can do so so
let's say we want to
create a variable named q that will
store the address of
p now what will be the type of this
variable we need
a pointer of a particular type to store
the address of a particular type of
variable
so to store a pointer to integer we will
have to say
that that we want a pointer
to pointers so we will put two asterisk
sign in front of the variable name
and now this variable q can store the
address
of p so with this first line
with this end astro gastric queue we
created
q let's say we created q at 2 0 5
and now we are seeing that q will store
the address of
p so q points to p
and the type of queue is int
asterisk asterisk with two we put two
asterisks
simple way to read this is that the type
of variable x is integer
so to store the address of x we will
need a pointer of type in
star so we will put one star to say that
this is a pointer to that particular
type and to store the address of
p we will need a pointer to instar so we
will put
one extra star to say that this is a
pointer to instar
and we can go on like this let's say we
want to declare
a pointer to pointer to pointer so in
stochastic is pointer to pointer
and we will put one more asterisk we can
put these three asterisk immediately
after this keyword int
or we can put it immediately before the
variable name like we have done in the
case of
q here let's say we define r as in
star star star so let's say r gets this
address
230 in the memory now r is
of type int
asterisk asterisk asterisk so it can
store the address of
int asterisk asterisk so it cannot store
the address of
x or p only a statement something like r
is equal to ampersand q will be valid
now i have translated my previous rough
code into
a working c program now let us assume
that
this program is working as per this
memory sketch that we are showing in the
right
now i will write some print statements
and you need to guess the output
so basically you have to assume that
these variables
x p q and r are allocated
these addresses what we are showing here
in the right so
the first print statement that i'm going
to write is
i want to print asterisk p
and this one should be simple for you
asterisk p
would be value stored at address in p so
this will be six
now the next statement that i want to
print is asterisk queue
so asterisk q will be a value at address
stored in queue
address stored in variable q is 215 so
this is nothing but the value of p
so this will be 225 and now i want to
print astro gastric cues so i want to
do day referencing twice first i want to
go to asterisk queue
astray q is this address 225 and now i
want to look at the
value at address 225 so this one will be
6. we could have avoided writing this
parenthesis here we could have said
astrich asterisk q only and that would
have also
that would have meant the same but it's
a good practice if we are
using this asterisk operator to use
parentheses wherever
we can do it because sometimes when we
are
also using other operators we are not
sure about the
precedence and we want to avoid unwanted
behaviors
now what about these two print
statements astro gastric r
and astro gastric asterisk r asterisk r
means
value in q which will be 215 and then
further
one more dereferencing will take us to
value in p which is 225 and one more
dereferencing will take us to value in
x which will be six if you see this is
really interesting
uh from r we are using one asterisk
operator and we are able to go to
q then we are using the asterisk
operator twice and we reach p
and then we are using the asterisk
operator thrice and we reach
x let's make some more changes in this
code and
run this in a real compiler so what i'll
do here is
i'll write a statement like this
and then after this statement i'll print
the value in x if you run this now as
you can see
asterisk p astro gastric q and asterisk
asteroid gastric
are all these three values are six
the address will not be same as we had
shown in the example
for obvious reasons and as you can see
we are able to modify
x by doing this chain of the referencing
using this variable
r uh if we would write something like
asterocastry
q is equal to
let's say something like this
now asterisk p is also uh referencing x
and asterocastric q
is also dereferencing x sorry we are
de-referencing here
so any guesses what will be the output
of this last print statement
well if you see x is incremented by 2
here
so this was pointer to pointer i
recommend that you write some of this
code yourself
and play a little bit in the coming
lessons we will use pointer to pointer
in some real problem scenarios so thanks
for watching
in our previous lessons we defined
pointer variables
and we also saw how to operate upon
pointer variables how to work with
pointer variables
in c or c plus program but we did not
really talk about
the real use cases of pointer variables
in what scenarios we may want to
use pointer variables so in this lesson
we will talk about
one of the use cases of pointer
variables and
the use cases using them using pointers
as function arguments and we also term
this as
call by reference so
let's discuss a scenario albert is a
beginner programmer
and he has recently learned about the
concept
user defined functions now he tries to
apply this concept
and he writes a simple c program like
this
what he is trying to achieve here is
that he has
an integer variable declared and
initialized in the main method
and he wants to increment the value in
this variable by one
so instead of writing something like a
plus plus or a
equal to a plus one instead of writing a
statement like this
he writes a function increment that will
take
an integer a as argument and inside this
function he's writing a statement like
a is equal to a plus 1 he calls this
function
increment from the main method passing a
as argument
and then he prints the value of a now
what he is expecting here
is that the value of a will be
incremented to 11
and hence the print statement will print
a
equal 11 but when he runs the program
the output of the print statement is
a equal 10. now albert does not
understand why this is happening
he has declared a variable a and then
he has initialized this variable to 10
and then he is passing the same a to the
function increment
and the same a is been being incremented
by 1
in this function so why the value of a
being
printed is not 11 why is it 10
now what albert does not understand well
or what he probably
forgot is that whenever we declare a
variable
inside a function then we call that
variable a local variable
because as such just using the variable
name
we can access that variable only inside
the same function in which we have
declared the variable
so these two a this a in the function
increment and this a in the function
main
are actually not the same a the a in the
function increment is another a
when main calls the method increment and
passes this
a as argument to the function then
only the value of a is copied to this
another a which is
another variable local to the increment
function
so what i'll do is i'll do couple of
modifications in this code to show you a
better picture
i will write two print statements in
this code
first print statement in the increment
method something like this
address of variable a in increment
is and as we know if we put ampersand
operator in front of the variable name
then we get the address
of that variable and i'll comment out
this print and
i'll write one more print in the main
method like this
and here i print that address of
variable a in main is ampersand a
let us now run this and see what happens
let me also put
an end of line after we print the
statement and the output is address of
variable a in
increment method is printed as four four
five
four four six zero and in main it is
equal to four four five four six six
zero
this two looks similar but they're not
the same one
is having four four six zero and then
and another is having four six six zero
what the values are is not important
what the addresses are is not important
what's
important is that these addresses are
different
if the a in main method and the a in
increment method
were same these two addresses would have
been
same to understand this even better
we will try to understand how things
happen in computers memory when a
program
executes when a program or an
application is
started then the computer sets aside the
machine
sets aside or reserves some amount of
memory
for the execution of this program the
memory that is set aside for the
application is divided into is typically
divided into
these four parts that we are showing
here
one part of memory is allocated to store
the various instructions in the program
the computer needs to keep all these
instructions in the memory
these instructions that we have in the
program like increment or declare these
variables
all these sequential instructions one
part of the memory
is one part of the allocated memory is
for
static or global variables if we do not
declare a variable
inside a function in c plus or c
then it is a global variable now global
variables
can be accessed and modified anywhere in
the program
unlike local variables which can be
accessed and modified within a
particular function or within a
particular code block
now the third part of the application's
memory is called as
stack and this is really important
this is where all the local variables go
and we will mostly be talking about
stack in this lesson and the fourth
fourth part is heap and we will come to
this later in
in our forthcoming lessons
of these four segments of the allocated
memory
uh the text segment the global variable
segment and the stack segment
these three are fixed and they are
decided when the program
starts executing the application however
can keep asking for
more memory for hits its heap segment
during its execution only
we will cover all of these things in
detail in our forthcoming lessons
please do not get scared by these terms
let us now see what happens when a
program
executes let us say this is our
computer's overall memory
the ram and as we know each byte in the
memory is addressable
so let's say uh the memory allocated for
our program is from address 2 0 0
to 8 0 0 and these are the various
segments
of our applications memory and of this
let's say
address 300 to 600 is allocated
for stack now there is more memory of
course in the ram
after address 800 and before address 200
okay so from 200 to 800 this part of the
memory is assigned for our program
let's say this c program that we have in
the left
now when a function is invoked like when
the
program starts the main method is
initially invoked
all the information about the method all
the information about the method call
like its parameters all the local
variables
the calling function to which it should
return
the current instruction at which it is
executing all this information
it's stored in the stack so we will take
out from
the stack some part for the main method
and
create a unit which we call stack frame
each function will have a stack frame
now we have a variable
a now memory is allocated for a from
this stack frame and the value
of a is 10. now the main method calls
increment function what happens when
main method calls
increment is that the machine says that
hey i will stop your execution for some
time
i will stop at this particular
instruction let me go ahead
and finish this method increment
and then i'll come back to the main
method once i'm done with increment
now another stack frame is allocated for
the increment method
and the parameters in increment method
like we have a parameter a
so fresh local variables are created
corresponding to these parameters
and whatever values have been passed are
copied to these variables these
parameters
now when we say a is equal to a plus 1
here in this statement then what happens
that
this a which is local to the increment
function in this particular stack frame
this a is incremented we cannot access a
variable it
outside its stack frame and now
increment finishes
when increment finishes the control
returns to the main method
and what the machine does is it clears
the stack frame that was allocated for
increment
and main method resumes again so main
method was paused at this particular
instruction increment
so lifetime of a local variable is
till the time the function is executing
now the next statement in main method is
a call to the function printf
printf is not a user defined function it
is a library function
the state of execution of main method is
kind of paused and printf is executing
now
we often call this particular structure
call stack or function call stack
whatever function is at the top of the
stack
is executing and remember this stack is
fixed in size so if you have a scenario
where one function
keeps calling another function in it
definitely like
in the case of in definite recursion
then the memory of this stack will
overflow and our program will crash
okay but that is not relevant for this
scenario
so now you must be getting a picture of
what happens when one function calls
another function
this a is in the stack frame of the main
method
main is our calling function and
increment is our called function
when we call a function in the calling
function the argument is also known as
actual argument and in the call function
the argument is known as
formal argument all that happens is the
actual argument is actually
mapped to a formal argument so when this
function call happens
a is mapped to a as an actual argument
is mapped to another a which is a formal
argument instead of a if we were having
an
x here so we would have written
something like in
x as is the argument and x is x plus 1
then
a would have been mapped to x so the
value of a will be copied to the
variable x
now when we make such a function call
where
we basically have one variable being
mapped to another variable that
value in one variable copied to another
variable then such a function call is
also called as
call by value so this is what albert was
doing
making a call by value and that's why he
was not able to get the desired result
but can we get the result that albert
wanted to have
all but wanted to use this variable a
which is
local to the main method inside the
increment function
can we really do so well yes we can do
so
if we use pointers as function arguments
let us now look at this code and i am
drawing only the stack here so that i am
able to show the simulation
of program execution neatly now what we
are doing here is that
we do not have an argument which is
integer
in this function increment we have an
argument which is pointer to integer
and pointer to integer as we know we
will it will store the address of an
integer
so now what we are doing is that in the
increment function we are passing the
address of
a so when the program will start
executing the main method will be
invoked first
let's say this is the stack frame of the
main method
let's say 300 to 350 this address is the
stack frame of main method
and there would be a local variable
a in this main method let's say the
address at which a
is stored is 308
this may not be in proportion but still
let's say this is how it is stored
now when main method calls increment
then a local variable corresponding to
the parameter
p is created and this is a pointer to
integer and the value that is passed to
this particular function
the value that gets stored in this
particular sorry it's not a function
it's a variable the value that gets
copied or stored in this particular
variable would be
308 the address of a
so p is pointing to a now in this
statement here when we say
asterisk b we dereference this address
so
we are saying here that asterisk p is
value at address stored in p so we say
that
increment the value stored at address p
by one
the value is stored at address three
zero eight gets incremented by
one so a is now 11.
so now when increment finishes and we
come back to the main method
and the next line gets executed which is
the print statement
then a is now 11. if you run this
program then what gets printed is
a equal 11. such a function call in
which instead of passing the value of a
variable we pass the
address of the variable so that we have
a reference to the variable
and we can de-reference it and perform
some operations is called
call by reference so if we use
pointers as functions arguments then we
are using call by reference
call by reference can save us a lot of
memory because instead of creating a
copy of
a large and complex data type if we just
use a reference to it
and using a reference will also cost us
some memory but very small amount of
memory
then we are saved from creating a new
copy of a complex data type
in the coming lessons we will see more
of the layout of applications memory
and what all things we can do using
pointers
so thanks for watching the concept of
pointers
and arrays in c or c plus plus
go together there is a very strong
relationship between these two concepts
and in this lesson we will be discussing
this relationship
when we declare an array let's say we
declare
and integer array a of size five
then we create five integer variables
named
a0 a1 a2
a3 and a4 now these five integers will
be
stored in the memory as a block of five
consecutive integers something like
this what we are showing here in the
right if a0 or the first element in the
array
is stored at address let's say address
200 and
a typical compiler modern day compiler
integer is stored in four bytes
so a one will be four bytes ahead of a0
at two zero four and a two will be at
two zero eight a three will be at two
one
two a four will be at 216. the overall
size of the array would be
20 bytes and these 20 bytes will be one
consecutive
block we are only showing the section of
the memory in which a
is stored sometimes we also show the
memory
horizontally something like this from
left to right
we increase the address but these two
representations are just
for the sake of understanding let's use
the horizontal representation of the
memory
this time i'll show this memory a little
more extending towards
the right so that i can accommodate a
couple of more variables
let's say apart from this integer array
a i have
an integer variable x and its value is 5
and let's say x is located at address
300 now let's say i have a pointer to
integer
p and in p i store the address of
x if we print p
then the value in p would be 300 so this
statement will
print 300 and if we de-reference
p and try to print the address stored in
try to print the value stored in this
location
p then the value would be 5.
this is fine but we also know that we
can do an operation something like
increment or decrement a pointer
variable by a constant
so we can do something like p equal p
plus 1
and this will take us to the address of
the next integer
and because integer is 4 bytes so now p
would be 3 0 304
so if i want to print p now then the
output should be 304 but
if we try to dereference p now and try
to print asterisk p
then we do not know the value at this
address so we cannot say what will be
printed
it's like we know that mr x lives at
address 300 but we do not know
who is his neighbor who lives at address
304
but for this integer array a let us say
i'm writing the same integer array in
the right here
which is located at address 200 if i
declare a pointer to integer p
and store the address of the first
element
by putting an ampersand operator in
front of a0
then printing p would give us in this
scenario
the output 200 and printing
asterisk p would give us but before that
let's
say we have these values in the array
let's fill up some values in the array
so asterisk p would be
2 now if i want to print
p plus 1 then the address would be
2 0 4 and if i d reference p plus 1
and try to print this value then it will
be 4
and similarly if we wanted the third
element in the array we could do
a p plus 2 here so using pointer
arithmetic makes sense in the case of
pointers because
in the case of arrays because we know
what is in the adjacent location
there is one more property of the array
if we just
use the name of the array a then a gives
us the pointer to the first element in
the array so we can write a statement
like
p is equal to a in fact we do not even
need to take this
address in another pointer variable if
we simply print
a then this gives us nothing but the
address of the first element in the
array
and if we want to dereference this and
try to print asterisk a
then this will give us the value so
if we want to perform something like we
want to print a plus 1
then this will give us the address to 0
4
and as to k plus 1 will give us the
address of the second element in the
array
value of the second element in the array
for an
element in the array at
index i we can retrieve the address of
this particular element in the memory
using either ampersand a i
or simply a plus
i and these two will give us the address
of a i and the value of a i can be
retrieved using either we simply use a i
or we can also use asterisks a plus i
and astrix a plus i will also give us
the value now this is an important
concept
we can write ampersand a i or a plus i
for each other and they mean the same
and we can write
a i or asterix a plus i for each other
and they mean the same
the address of the first element in the
array
can also be called the base address and
a
simply using the variable name a gives
us the base address
of the array let us now see some code
examples
and try to solidify our concepts further
in my program let's say we have an
integer array a now as we said if we
simply print
a then this should give us the address
of the first element in the array
and we can also get the address of the
first element in the array by
using ampersand operator in front of a0
if i simply print a0 it will print the
first element in the array
and we can also print the first element
in the array
by using asterisk operator in front of
the variable name a let us now run this
and see what happens
and i also need to put an end line after
each of these print statements
okay so the output is that the first two
lines are the same
they're giving us the address of the
first element in the array
and the second two lines are giving us
the value in fact if we run a loop like
this from 0 to index 4
then we can print address of the element
at index i as ampersand a i or a plus i
and we can print the value of ith
element as a
i and asterix a plus i
now if we see the output here this is a
fresh run a new run so
the address allocations will change but
if we see the address printed in
two lines for a0 is same the value is
same again for a1 the address is same
four bytes ahead of the previous address
and the value is as expected
and we can go on like this
now one more thing even though just
using the variable name
a returns us pointer to the
base address or the address of the first
element
and we can equate the variable name
a against some pointer variable like
this we cannot do something like a plus
plus
increment the value of a this will give
us compilation error
we can do something like p plus plus
once we assign
a to some point or variable other
pointer variable but
incrementing a itself would be invalid
so this was how arrays are stored in
memory
and how the addresses can be manipulated
and how we can access the values using
pointers in the next lessons in the
coming lessons we will talk about
character arrays and we will talk about
passing arrays
as function arguments so thanks for
watching
in this lesson we will be talking about
one more scenario in which
the concept of arrays and pointers
go together and this scenario is when
you pass
an array as function argument
let us see a code example where we pass
array as function argument and try to
analyze it
i will write a simple c program in which
i will write
a function that will give me the sum of
all the elements in an integer array
this function will take an integer array
as argument
this is one of the ways to pass an
integer array an array in general as
argument
this would be the data type and this
would be the name of the
array and in the main method we have
declared and initialized an array named
a
now in the main method we will call this
function sum of elements
and pass it the array a as argument
and of course we need to write the body
of this function
sum of elements i will declare two
variables
i and another variable sum and
initialize it to zero
i will be used to run a loop so we will
iterate through
all the elements in the array a that is
passed as argument
but wait a minute we do not know the
size of this array a
is there some way to know the size of
the array one of the
ways to find out the size of the array
and by the size of the array we mean the
number of elements in the array here
is to use the function size off so
if we write something like size of a
here in the main method
then this will give us the size of the
array a in bytes
array has five integers and in a typical
compiler
and i know for sure that in this
compiler an integer is stored in four
bytes so
size of a will return 20. if we want to
know the
number of elements in the array then we
can do something like
divide the size of the size and bytes
of the whole array by size of one
integer
so we will say size of a upon size of
each integer in y the size of a0 would
give us the
number of elements in the array and i'll
write this particular line
below this line the line where we are
calling the function sum of elements
now what we can do is we could either
pass the size of the array as another
argument
so that would be cool and then we can
run the loop
starting 0 till index size
-1 and we keep on adding each element
to this variable sum and finally
we return sum and finally we will write
a
print statement something like this
to print the sum of all the elements in
the array let us now run this program
and
see what happens the output on console
is that
the sum of elements is equal to 15
5 plus 4 plus 3 plus 2 plus 1 is 15. so
this is all right
now what i want to do is i want to
modify this code a little
i do not want to pass the size as
argument here
i want to calculate the size of the
array inside this function
so we will not be passing this size as
argument here so there will be
there will be just one argument the
array
so we have this array as argument the
array a
and we calculate the size here as total
size of the array in bytes
upon the size of one integer in bytes
let us now run this program and see what
happens
oops this seems to be some problem
because the sum of elements
that we have as output on console here
is equal to 1 it should be 15
and why is it so to explain this
behavior i will write
two more print statements one in the
function
sum of elements where i will print the
size of
a and the size of a0
i will be calling these two functions
size off upon
a and upon a 0 respectively and we will
write one more print statements in the
main method
it will again be the same thing printing
the size of a in bytes and the size of a
0 in bytes let us now see the output
in the method sum of elements size of a
is equal to 4 bytes
size of a0 is equal to 4 bytes in the
method main size of a is equal to 20
bytes and the size of
a 0 again is 4 bytes to understand this
concept
why the size of a is 4 bytes in the
method sum of elements and it
is equal to 20 bytes in the main method
we need to dive deep into how compiler
interprets
an array as function argument once again
i will draw this
familiar memory diagram the memory
assigned to an application or a program
is typically divided into these four
parts we have talked about this in our
previous lessons
for the execution of function calls we
use
stack section of the memory this green
rectangle here is
our stack now when the program starts
executing first the main method is
invoked
so some amount of memory from the stack
is allocated
corresponding to the call of the main
method
and this particular section or this
particular part
is also called the stack frame of a
method
all the local variables reside within
this stack frame
now here in main method we have
two local variables one is the array a
and another local variable is integer
total
so around 20 bytes if integer is
4 bytes exactly 20 bytes in fact would
be allocated
from this stack frame for the local
variable a the array a
and four bytes for total the variable
total
and there would be some more information
in the stack frame now when the program
execution reaches this particular line
where we make a call to sum of elements
then the execution of
main is paused and another
stack frame is allocated to execute the
function
sum of elements we have talked about
this
call stack growth and function execution
a number of times in our previous
lessons okay now this
is a local variable this parameter is a
local variable to
the function sum of elements it is not
this a in the
main method what happens when we make a
function call is that
the value of this particular local
variable in the main method
or we should rather say the value from
the variable in the calling function is
copied to the variable in the called
function
so ideally we should have one more a
local to the function called sum of
elements
and the value of a should be copied into
this parameter a
so we would have another array named a
taking 20 bytes in the stack frame of
sum of elements
and it would have the same value same
elements
as the array a in the calling function
main but actually this doesn't happen
when compiler sees an array as
function argument it does not copy the
whole array
what it actually does it it just
creates a pointer variable by the same
name instead of creating the whole
array it just creates a pointer
to the data type of the array so in this
case it will be pointed to integer
and the compiler just copies the address
of the first element in the array of the
calling function so let's say uh the
starting address address of the first
element
in this array a that belongs to the main
method is 200 so
in sum of elements all that happens is a
pointer to integer is created and the
value
in this pointer to integer is 200. the
compiler
implicitly converts this int
a to something like in star a
that is this a here in this particular
format is not interpreted as an
array but it is interpreted as pointer
to integer
so whether you write int space variable
name following
these brackets or you write something
like in star space a
they're both the same we have a term for
this
instead of copying the value of the
variable we are just
copying and storing the address of the
variable
so we make a call by reference here
arrays
always are passed as a reference
parameters
and this makes a lot of sense because
arrays can be
really large in size so it does not make
much sense to create a new copy of the
array each time
it is unnecessarily using a lot of
memory
so for arrays there is no call by value
there is always a call by
reference and that's why this size of a
here
would give us 4 as output because a
is a pointer to integer here well here
in the main method a is an
array so this format of
passing array as function argument where
we put these
braces to tell that this is an array is
actually interpreted
something like this by the compiler
you can put an asterisk sign here or you
can put an asterisk sign here it's the
same thing
it makes more sense to write it like
this so a is actually interpreted as
pointer to integer that's why when we
pass
array as function argument there is no
way to know the
number of elements in the array by using
a trick like this
we actually need to pass the size of the
array
so i'd rather move this
size calculation in the main method and
pass the size
and when we run this program now
we get the output as expected sum of
elements is
15. now we should always keep in mind
that
a variable name which is used as an
array
is different from a variable which is
pointed to integer
even though the compiler gives us some
privileges like we can use
the name of the array to get the pointer
to the first element
like in this function sum of elements we
could say something like
to pass the first element we should we
could have said ampersand a0 the address
of the first element
but if we just use a instead of using
ampersand a0
then that is allowed if a is an array
but if a is an array we cannot do
something like
incrementing or decrementing it like
pointer variables
with pointer variables we can do a
couple of other stuffs
and if we have a pointer to the starting
address of the array
we can pretty much use it like a
variable name for
array because a i is interpreted as
value at address a plus i so we need to
keep these differences and similarities
in mind it's a little tricky
there is one more thing because the
array is passed by
reference we can modify the elements of
the array in the
called function and it would re reflect
in the calling function
so let's say instead of
calculating the sum total we want to
double all the elements
each individual element in the array so
our code will go something like this
i want to say that a i is now twice a i
and we will not return an integer let's
say the return type is
void and in the main method i'll clear
all this stuff
and what i'll do is i'll simply run a
loop
to print all the elements in the array
okay let us now run this and see what
happens
oops i forgot to call the function
double
i must make a call before i print the
elements okay let us now run this
if you see the elements in the array a
are modified each element is
twice its previous value because this is
called by reference the same
copy of the array a
is modified using d referencing
so this was array as function arguments
an important use case of array as
function argument
is when we work with strings in c
so strings in c are nothing but
character arrays
this concept really becomes important in
the context of
character arrays we will be talking
about it in the coming lessons
so thanks for watching in our lesson so
far we have seen
how the concepts of arrays and pointers
go together
now in this lesson we are going to talk
about character arrays
how we can work with character arrays
using pointers
now when we talk about character arrays
in c we
basically want to talk about strings
strings are group or set of characters
and real world data like names
phrases and sentences all of these are
strings to us so these are some of the
examples of strings
character arrays become all the more
important because
we use them to store strings and then
perform
a lot of operations on strings like
modifying a string
copying a string concatenating two
strings or
finding out properties of strings like
finding out the length of a string
to be able to work with strings
efficiently in c
and there are a couple of things that we
need to understand and the first thing
that we
need to understand is how we store
strings in character arrays
to be able to store a string in a
character array the first requirement is
that
the character array should be large
enough to accommodate the string
and what is a large enough character
array a large enough character array is
a character array
of size greater than or equal to
number of characters in the string
plus one so let's say if our string is
a name of four characters like john
then the size of the array should be
greater than or equal to
5. now the obvious question would be why
do we need space for one extra character
isn't it that if we declare a character
array of size
4 we can store all the characters in
john j will go at the 0th index
o will go at the 1 index h and
n will go at second and third index
respectively
so i'm storing all the data isn't it
let's try to understand it this way
let's say we have a character array of
size 8
let's say this is a logical view of our
array c
and we want to store the string john in
this particular array
we have indices from 0 to 7 and this is
an array of size 8.
so we can store j at the zeroth index o
at the 1th index
h at the 2th index and n at the 3th
index
so we have stored all the characters of
the string john in this
array but if you see we have not stored
one information
now we have not stored the information
that this particular character
n is the last character in the string so
the string ends
at index three so let's say if we pass
this string to a function
and that has to print the string john or
find out the length of the string that
we have stored in this array
then how would the function know that
the string is only till index 3 even
though
we have not filled anything in these
indices at
4 5 6 and 7 there would be some garbage
value there
so either we pass this extra information
or we do something else
to store this information that this is
the end of the string in the character
array
this is the used part of the string and
this is the unused part
we use a simple design at the end of the
string in the next position we put
a null character and null character has
a sky value 0
and we can put a null character at
position 4 in this example something
like this
within single quotes we put a forward
slash and
number 0 this is null character all the
functions for
string manipulation in c expect that
strings will be null terminated
so this is a rule a string in c has to
be terminated by
a null character and that's why we need
one extra space
to store this null character let us try
to see some running code that will help
us
understand this concept better what i
have done here is i have
taken a character array of size 4 and i
have filled in the characters but i have
not used any space
to null terminate it and then i am using
the printf function this percentile s
here tells that
i want to print a string and then i am
passing this
array c uh let us run this program and
see what happens
as we can see there are these bunch of
characters
that are getting printed after john and
this is happening because
we have broken the assumption for the
printf function that
my string that our string will be null
terminated
so that's why this undefined behavior is
coming if we change the size of the
character array to five and put
a null termination something like this
at fourth index
and then things will be fine now even if
we change the size of the array to 20
print a function will print till it
finds
a null character so it only prints on
the first four characters in the array
and it's not just the print function
there are bunch of
functions we have this library string
dot h
that gives us a bunch of function for
string manipulation
so all these functions assume that the
string will be null terminated
so this is one contract that we have to
follow
let's say we want to use one function
strlen
string length to find out this length of
the string
i'll print something like this let's run
this and see
as you can see the output is length is
equal to 4 even though
the array is of size 20. so string
length function also counts till
it sees a null character in
our program instead of writing these
characters individually at this
positions
we could have used string literals
string literals are
a group of characters within double
quotation marks so we could have written
something like this
and this would have initialized c as
this string and the null termination for
a string literal is implicit it is
always
stored with a null termination in memory
remember when we declare and initialize
a character array like
this this has to happen in one line we
cannot do something like we declare
in one line and then we go on and modify
this in the next line this will be
invalid
uh we could also avoid writing this size
here
and this would have been fine in this
case the size of c
will be five units five bytes where one
byte stores one character
so it would be just enough to store the
string
john so if we try to print the size and
bytes of c
using this size of function then size
and bytes is five
one character is stored in one byte so
space has been allocated for five
characters
but the length is four because the null
character does not count in the length
if we write something like c4 is equal
to
this particular string literal with four
characters this will give us compilation
error because the compiler
will force this particular array to be
of minimum size 5. there is one more
syntax of initialization
we can put all these characters as a
comma separated list
within these braces but in this case the
null termination will not be implicit we
will have to do it explicitly
and the size of the array has to be
greater than or equal to the number of
characters here so it should be greater
than or equal to five
okay so these are some of the ways to
initialize character array
the next thing that we need to
understand is
arrays and pointers are different types
that are used in similar manner
now what does it really mean let's say
we declare a character array c1 of size
6
and initialize it with this string
literal and let's say this is how it
gets stored in the memory
array is stored in one contiguous block
of memory so let's say the first
character is at address 200 one
character is of size one byte so the
next character will be at address 2 0
1 and the next will be at 2 0 2 and so
on
now c 1 is the variable name for this
whole
array now what i'll do is i'll declare a
variable which is a pointer to character
let's name this c2 so let's say we get
this variable c2 somewhere in the memory
a pointer variable in a typical
architecture is stored in 4 bytes
so this variable will also have some
address let's say this variable is at
address 400
i'm just picking up these numbers for
example sake now what we can do is we
can write a statement like this
c2 is equal to c1 now even though c1
is a character array is a variable name
for character array
and c2 is a variable which is pointer to
character this particular expression is
valid
just using the name of the array
actually
returns the address of the first element
in the array so
what this expression what this statement
will do is
it will fill in the address 200 in c2 so
c2 now points
to the first element in the array
now we can use this variable c2 which is
a character pointer
just like c1 to read and write
into the array so if i write something
like
print c to i let's say we want to print
c 2
1 then the output will be l
and we can even modify the array let's
say we want to modify the character at
zeroth index to
a so the string will be modified
and will become this now when we write
c2i
for any position i it is nothing but
asterisk c2 plus i
so c2 is the base address c2 plus i
will take you to the address of the ith
element
so in this case let's say c2 plus 2 will
be 202
and if we put this asterisk operator we
are basically
dereferencing and finding out the value
so these two syntaxes are
alternate syntaxes and even if it is
an array name we can write these two as
substitutes for each other
so this was all the similarity in how we
actually
use them use arrays and pointers
to read and write let us now look at the
differences
we cannot modify an array with a
statement like this
c2 equals c1 is valid but c1 equals c2
is not valid uh it does not make sense
this will give you compilation error we
cannot even say c1 is equal to
c1 plus 1 we cannot increment or
decrement
this variable c1 now we can do it for c2
which is a pointer variable we can say
c2 plus plus so c2
now points to the next element with this
statement here
all that will happen is c2 will become
201 so
instead of pointing here it's now
pointing to this particular element e
to traverse an array we run a loop and
we use a local variable let's say i
and increment it in the loop if we have
a pointer variable we can just keep on
incrementing the pointer
and we can traverse the list we can
reverse the array
we will keep doing this c2 plus plus so
we must understand where we have an
array and where we have a pointer and
what we can do with
which one now the next thing that we
need to understand
is that arrays are always passed to
functions by reference
when we pass arrays to functions we only
pass the base address
of the array in a pointer variable and
we do not pass
a whole copy of the array the compiler
does not let you do
do that we have talked about this in
detail in our previous lesson
arrays as function arguments let us look
through some code and try to understand
this better
in my code i have declared a character
array of size 20
and i have stored a string of length 5
in this character array
the null termination is implicit if we
are using string literal
now i want to print this string but i do
not want to use the library function
printf i want to write my own function
print i want to pass this
array to the function and this function
should print the string part in a
character array
the argument to the function we have
talked about this earlier can be
something like this to say that we are
receiving an array here
but the compiler actually interprets
this
as this so the compiler forces that only
the address
of the character array or the address of
any array
be received as argument to the function
because arrays are large in size so it
is inefficient to create a
copy of the same array for each function
okay so let's write the logic now now
this print function does not have any
idea that this particular array
is of size 20 it only knows the base
address
so what we can do is we can have a
variable i initialize it to 0 and we can
say something like this
while ci is not equal to
null character we can print the
character ci
and then we will increment i and when we
find
a null character we can come out of this
loop and print
an end of line once again this print
function does not know that this
character array is of size 20 it only
knows the base address
and that's why in the printf function
when we were not null terminating an
array we were printing all the garbage
value
even after the array was finished
because until we get a null character we
do not know
where to stop and we keep on going into
unwanted memory locations
now this code should work yes this is
fine
in my code here i'm using percentile c
here to say that we want to print
character
and ci we can also write asterisk c plus
i
as substitute for c i and that will also
mean the same
sometimes you'll see this kind of syntax
as we talked earlier both of these
syntax asterisk c plus i and ci
are valid they are the same there is one
more thing in our code that we may do we
may not
choose to have this particular variable
i we could simply say that
while asterisk c is not equal to null
print asterisk c and then increment
c itself and this code will also work
why this code will work i'll leave it as
an exercise for you to think
in the coming lessons we will implement
more functions for string manipulation
this is it for now thanks for watching
in part one of our lesson
on character arrays and pointers we saw
how we can store strings in character
arrays
and we also saw how we can work with
character arrays using pointers in some
of the basic scenarios
whenever we are working with pointers
it's really important that we
visualize how things are happening in
the memory
so the first thing that we will do in
this lesson is we will simulate the
program that we had written in the
previous lesson to
print the characters of a string
and see what goes where in the memory
and we will also look into the concept
of string constants
and constant pointers so this is where
we had left in our previous lesson
we have written a function print to
print the characters in a string
in the main method we have a character
array of size 20
but we have stored a string of length 5
in it
now we have used a string literal so a
null termination is implicit
we have talked about this earlier so let
us
step through this code and see how it is
working now once again i have drawn this
familiar diagram
the memory that is allocated for
execution of a program is typically
divided into these
four parts these four sections one part
of the memory stores the
instructions in the program we call that
the code segment or the text
segment one one section stores the
global variables and stack is where all
the information regarding function call
execution
and all the local variables go whenever
we are writing a program whenever we are
executing a program we should always
visualize
what variable goes where
or what data goes where and what is the
scope of that variable or data
okay so let us run through this code and
see what is happening in the memory
when this program will start executing
first the main method
main function will be invoked whenever
a function is called some amount of
memory from the stack
is allocated for the execution of that
function it's called
the stack frame of that function so let
us say
this stack frame from address 100 250 is
allocated for the main function
stack is one contiguous block of memory
so let us say in the stack the memory
increases from bottom to top
all the local variables of a function go
into the stack frame of the function
so when we declare a character array uh
20 bytes from this stack frame will be
allocated for this particular character
array
let's say they are allocated from
address 100 to 120.
each character is stored in one byte so
we need 20 bytes
for character array of size 20. apart
from local variables there may be some
more information
in stack frame so that's why we have
some more space and now the control
of the program goes to this statement
print c
as soon as we make a call to another
function from a function the execution
of that particular function
is paused at that particular line and
the machine goes on to execute
the called function the call function is
allocated
stack frame on top of the calling
function so print will be allocated a
stack frame on top of
main function whatever function is at
the top of this stack in
at any point is executing main will wait
for this function to finish
let's say this particular stack frame is
from 150 to 170
main is paused and print is executing
right now
now print will also have a local
variable c but this will be a
pointer variable a pointer variable
takes
four byte of memory in a typical
architecture so this will be
taking four bytes so let's say starting
address
one five four in this stack frame we
have four bytes for this particular
character pointer so this c
in main is actually not the same c in
print
the c in main and the c in print are
different
they have different scopes we could have
named this particular variable
a or ptr or whatever but all that
happens when we make this particular
call
to print and pass this c here
is that the address 100 which is the
base address of the array
is passed to the print function and the
print function keeps it
stores it in a pointer variable
sometimes it may confuse us when we are
using the same
local variable name in the calling
function and the same
argument name in the called function but
we must always understand that they are
different
okay to run through this code further
i'll clear some space
here now i'll draw this array c
outside the stack here now we have an
array of size 20
but we are only showing the first six
positions in the array from address 100
205
and that's why it is extending towards
the right
the sixth character is a null character
and the first five characters
are the characters of word hello and now
we have this another guy which is c
of print which is a character pointer at
address 154 that stores address 100 so
it points to
the first element of the array now let's
come back to our program execution
let's say we are here initially uh i'll
mark the statement that
is executing by this green arrow let's
name these two guys this guy's c but
this guy
is an array local to main and this is
also c but it is a character pointer
local to print
okay so now here what we are saying is
while asterisk c is not equal to the
null character
when we put this asterisk operator in
front of a pointer variable
we are looking at the value at that
particular address
so at this stage when c is pointing to
the
base address asterisk c is h so this
condition is not true
we will go to this line printf that will
simply print asterisk c
which is h let's write down the output
here so we have
printed h so far and then we say c
plus plus if we understand pointer
arithmetic from our previous lessons
incrementing a pointer by one unit
increments the address by size of the
data type
that the pointer points to c here is a
pointer to character data type and
character data type is
one byte so c plus one c plus plus is
saying
c is equal to c plus one so c now
becomes hundred and one
so now c points to the second character
in the array
and once again we come to verifying this
condition in the while loop
asterisk c is e here it's not null now
once again we will go inside the loop
and print
e and we will keep on going like this
until the address in this pointer
variable reaches
105 now here the value at this
particular address is
null character so the loop will not
execute
we will come to this statement to print
an end of line
and the execution of print function will
finish
so this particular stack frame for print
will be cleared from the stack will be
deallocated and now main will resume and
finish
so with pointers we should always know
what's going where
in the memory okay so let us now
modify this particular code to learn
some more concepts
now what i'm going to do in my code is
instead of
creating a character array of size 20
i'll create a character pointer named c
and equate it against
a string literal in a statement like
this and if you run this program
and the output will be the same what
really happens is
if you use the string literal in
initialization statement of an array
something like this
and then the string gets stored in the
space that is allocated to the array
so in this case it will go into the
stack in this character array of size
20 but if you use the string literal
elsewhere in a statement like this or
maybe when we do something like passing
a string literal
to a function then in these cases
the string gets stored as a constant
during the compile time most probably it
will be stored in the
text segment of the application memory
and
it cannot be modified so if you write a
statement like this let's say you want
to
change the first character of on this
constant string to
a or running this program will give you
an error
will cause a crash okay coming back to
having
a character array now if we have a
character array and we are passing
uh the address of the array to a
function
that function receives it in a character
pointer
now using this pointer we can modify
the data in this particular array so if
i say something like this
we first change the first character to a
and then we are printing the characters
and then as you can see it is possible
to do so
now sometimes we may want a function
just to read a string and not
write anything to force this kind of
behavior we can
change our argument to const character
pointer
now if we run this code this code will
give us compilation error
now we can read whatever is there in the
array that is passed
but we cannot write to any of the
positions this code
will work fine pointers are really
tricky and even the most experienced
programmers
write buggy code when they're using
pointers i recommend that you get
your hands dirty by writing some code
yourself that's the best way to learn
so this is it for this lesson thanks for
watching
in this lesson we are going to talk
about pointers and multi-dimensional
arrays
as we have seen in our previous lessons
the concepts of pointers
and arrays go together we have already
talked about pointers in context of
one-dimensional arrays
how we can work with one-dimensional
arrays using pointers now let's see how
we can work with
a two-dimensional array or a
three-dimensional array
or a multi-dimensional array in general
using pointers
to understand this concept once again we
first need to understand how
multi-dimensional arrays
are organized in computers memory let's
first go back to the organization of
one-dimensional arrays in memory
when we declare a one-dimensional array
something like this
let's say we are declaring an integer
array a
of five elements then basically what we
are doing is we are creating
five different integer variables that we
can name a0
a1 a2 a3 and a4
as one contiguous block of memory
what i'm showing here is a section of
computer's memory
array a let's say is stored in this
section of memory
and the starting address of a is 200
as we know each byte in a computer's
memory has
an address and if we assume that
an integer is stored in 4 bytes which is
what it takes
in a typical compiler then the block of
4 bytes
starting address 200 will be a0 as i'm
showing here
block of 4 bytes starting address 204
will be a1
next block of 4 bytes starting at s208
will be
a2 and so on i'll fill in some values
here
we had seen this earlier also in our
previous lessons if we write a statement
like this
then this is all right if i just use the
variable name
a then name of the array in an
expression
basically returns a pointer to the first
element of the array
because this is an array of integers so
each element will be an integer
hence a returns a pointer to integer
once i have written a statement like int
asterisk b equal
a i can use pointer arithmetic and d
referencing to
access all the elements in the array if
i would just try to print the address
stored in p
and i'm not using full printf statement
here my output will be 200.
if i would simply try to dereference p
then output will be 2. if i would try to
print something like
asterix p plus 2 then output will be 6
because we have an integer pointer
adding 1
will take us to the address of the next
integer
which will be 4 bytes ahead adding 2
will take us to the address of
next to next which will be 8 bytes ahead
if we would be printing p plus 2 it will
be 208 and if we would
day reference and we would print asterix
p plus 2 then it will be
value 6. we have already discussed
pointer arithmetic in our previous
lessons
now language gives us this flexibility
that we can use
the name of the array just like a
pointer
for all the d referencing so instead of
doing all of this printing with p if we
would do all of this with
a it will still be the same
in fact astex a plus i is same as
a i these are alternate syntax
and a plus i is same as ampersand a i
both will give us the address
of the ith element in the array please
remember that even though we can use the
name of the array
just like pointer for all this
dereferencing and arithmetic
it's not same as a pointer variable so
we can do something like
p equal a like what we have done here
so this is all right but we cannot do
the other way we cannot say
a equal p this will give you compilation
error
so this is pretty much how we would use
pointers with one-dimensional arrays
let's now say we want to create
a two-dimensional array i will declare a
two-dimensional array of integers named
b something like this
now what we are doing here is we are
creating
array of array we are creating two
one-dimensional arrays
of three elements each this time
b0 and b1 are both one-dimensional
arrays of three integers each
a one-dimensional array of three
integers would be
12 bytes if each integer is four bytes
in size
so if i have to show this in memory the
first
block of 12 bytes starting address 400
will be b0 and the next
block of 12 bytes starting address
412 will be b1
as we had said name of the array returns
a pointer to the first element
in the array this time each element is
not an integer each element is a
one-dimensional array of three integers
so if i would write a statement like
this int asterisk p
equal b then this will give me a
compilation error
because b will return a pointer to 1d
array of three
integers and not just a pointer to
integer
the type of a pointer matters not when
you have to read the address
it matters when you de-reference or when
you perform pointer arithmetic
it's really important that we understand
this we can define a pointer to
one d array of three integers like this
and now if i'll equate this with p
this is all right equate b
with b this time if i would print
just b which is same as printing address
of
b0 this will be 400
if i will print asterisk b which will be
same as
b0 then b0 this time is
variable name for a one dimensional
array of three integers
so just using the name b0 will return us
pointer to the first integer in b0 which
will be accessed
as b00 so i'm putting this ampersand
sign here in front of b00
first integer in b0 will be this block
of 4 bytes
its address once again is 400
okay now i have also created three
blocks of four bytes each in both
b0 and b1 and also fill in some values
now i'm going to write some print
statements and i want you
to guess the output what will be the
output if i'll try to
print b plus 1 i will write the address
of
each block of 4 bytes in the 2d array
the address
of a block is the address of the first
byte in the block
okay so what will be the value of b plus
one
b this time is returning us a pointer to
one dimensional array of three integers
so if i would do a pointer arithmetic
like adding plus one
we are moving to the next 1d array of
three integers
so we will be moving to address 400 plus
size of one dimensional array of three
integers
in bytes so output will be 412
which makes sense because p plus 1 is
same as
ampersand b1 or address of b1
and address of b1 is 412.
okay now what if i print asterix b plus
one
when we are putting an asterisk signs
when we are trying to dereference this
is when
the type of pointer becomes important b
is a pointer to one dimensional array of
three integers
so b plus one is also a pointer to one
dimensional array of three integers
and when we will de-difference we will
get this whole one-dimensional array of
three integers starting address four
hundred and twelve
asterix b plus one is same as b1 so we
will get b1
now printing b1 means using the
name of this one-dimensional array b1
which should return us the pointer to
the first
integer in b1 so asterisk b plus 1 is
basically pointer to this
integer at address 412
once again this output will be 412.
all these expressions asterisks p plus 1
or
b1 or ampersand b1 0 are returning us
pointer to integer okay now you need to
gear up because i'm going to give you
some tough ones to decode
what will be the output if i will print
asterisk
b plus 1 plus 2 take some time and think
about it
asterix b plus 1 as we saw above will
return
an integer pointer to first integer in
b1
to the integer at address 412 adding 2
here is performing pointer arithmetic
because asterix b plus 1 is a pointer to
integer
storing this address 412 adding two is
basically
going to the address of next to next
integer
which will mean skipping 8 bytes and and
going to reference integer
at address 420 asterisk b
plus 1 in this expression can be written
as b1 simply b1
because they are substitutes for each
other they are alternate syntax
so this is same as b1 plus 2 and once
again
these expressions are returning pointer
to integer they are returning pointer to
this element
b12 and that's why we can also say
ampersand b12
all these three once again are same
let's do one more print
if you can get this one right i can say
that you're good
working with two dimensional arrays
using pointers what will be the output
for this expression asterisk of
asterisks
asterisks of asterisk b plus 1
what will be the output for this
expression think about it
whenever you encounter an expression
with pointed arithmetic
and dereferencing then you must go step
by step
here b is returning us
pointer to one dimensional array of size
three
one dimensional array of three integers
and d
referencing it will give us the one
dimensional array
so asterisk b as we know will give us
b0 as should be is same as b0
now b0 in my expression because b0 is
named for
a one-dimensional array returns me
pointer to the first integer
in the one-dimensional array so b0
returns pointer to integer
we will get a pointer to this integer at
address 400.
now what will happen if you will add one
to an integer pointer
it will take you four bytes ahead to the
next integer it will return your pointer
to the next integer so we will get a
pointer to this integer at address four
zero four
asterisk b plus 1 is basically ampersand
b01
and with this final dereferencing we can
get rid of this ampersand so the overall
expression
will be b01 which is 3
for a 2 dimensional array b
i j where b is named for my 2
dimensional array and
i and j are some indices can be written
as
asterisks of b i
plus j and once again b i can be written
as
asterix of b plus i
so these three expressions are same i
would recommend trying all of this in
real code
so far this discussion has been about
working with two dimensional arrays
using pointers
we will stop here for this lesson in
another lesson we will
play with some real code and we will
also discuss how we can
work with an array of further higher
dimension like a three-dimensional array
we will also discuss passing of arrays
to functions
through pointers this is it for this
lesson thanks for watching
in our previous lesson we saw how we can
work with two dimensional arrays using
pointers
now in this lesson we will see how we
can work with arrays of further higher
dimensions like
three dimensional arrays using pointers
we will also see how we can pass
multi-dimensional arrays as
arguments to functions because that's
one scenario where pointers once again
will come into picture
i will start with a quick recap of what
we have discussed in our previous lesson
whenever we create a multi-dimensional
array and let's pick up the example of
two dimensional array that we had
created in our previous lesson
we must think of the multi-dimensional
array as
array of arrays array basically
is a collection of similar things of
similar objects
so a multi-dimensional array is
basically a collection of arrays
this array b here is a collection
of one-dimensional arrays of three
elements each
we have two one-dimensional arrays of
three elements
each what i have tried to show in this
figure is how
array b will be organized in memory i
have assumed that the starting address
of the array is
400 each cell storing an integer
here is a block of 4 bytes as we know
each
byte in computers memory has an address
i am not drawing all the bytes partition
for all the bytes i am trying
blocks of 4 bytes each and that's why
i'm writing only the starting address of
each
block you can imagine a block of four
bytes
something like this the starting address
is 400 let's say each partition here
is one byte so the next
byte has address 401 and the next one
has address 402 and the next one has
address 403
overall this first block of 12 bytes
that will that contains these three
integers 2 3 and 6 that i'm showing in
yellow here
is my first one-dimensional array that i
can call b0
and this next block of 12 bytes is my
second one-dimensional array of three
integers that i can call
b1 so we have two one-dimensional arrays
in our collection we have two
collections of three integers
each in our collection and everything is
organized in one contiguous block of
memory
now let's look at this b0 is from byte
address
400 till 411
we have three integers and we have four
bytes for each integer
the first integer that we can access as
element at
zeroth index of b0 is taking four bytes
starting address 400
the next integer that can be accessed as
b01 one element of b0
will take next four bytes starting 404
and the next one will be b02 element at
index two of p0
and similarly we will have four bytes
for
zeroth element of b1 four bytes for one
element and four bytes for element at
index
2 of b1 as we had seen in our previous
lesson when we just use the
array name then it returns us a pointer
to the first
element of the array here b is
a two dimensional array it is an array
of one dimensional arrays of size
three so b will basically return us a
pointer to
one dimensional array of three elements
pointed to one dimensional array of
three
integers in this statement i have
declared
a variable which is pointed to one
dimensional array of three
integers and the name of the variable is
p a statement like this is all right
a statement like this will not be all
right because b will not return
a pointer to integer b will return a
pointer to one dimensional
array of three integers now i will write
three print statements that i had also
written in our previous lesson
i am not writing the complete syntax for
printf okay so once again you need to
tell me what will be the
output if we would print these three
expressions
we have p asterisk b and b0
well for all these three output will be
400
here when we say b just using the array
name b
will return us a pointer to the first
one dimensional array in b
the type of a pointer variable is
relevant only
when we are trying to dereference or
perform pointed arithmetic
but if we would just try to print the
address
stored in the pointer variable it will
be the starting address
address of the first byte of a block of
memory
so if we have a pointer to this
one-dimensional array that is storing 2
3 and 6
then its address is 400. now when we did
an
asterisk b which is same as b0
we de-referenced and now we have got the
complete one-dimensional array b0
now if i use b0 because b0 is a
one-dimensional array
we will get a pointer to the first
integer in b0
so we will get a pointer to b00
this block of 4 bytes starting address
400
once again if we would just print the
address then the
starting address of this block is 400
that's why the output here is 400 even
if i would print
ampersand b00 the output will be
400 b and asterisk b are both
returning as pointers the difference is
that b is returning
pointer to a one dimensional array of
three integers
while asterisk b is returning pointer to
an integer
when we are just printing the address
both these objects
the complete one-dimensional array b0
and the first
element in b0 have the same starting
address so the same starting address
will be printed
the type of pointer plays role when you
try to dereference or when you try to
perform
pointed arithmetic we had also seen in
our previous lesson that
b i j can be written as asterisks of
b i plus j if b i for some value of
i is a one dimensional array then b i
will give us an integer pointer will
return
us an integer pointer to the first
integer in bi
then adding j is basically performing
pointed arithmetic
and getting a pointer to integer at
index
j in one dimensional array bi and then
finally this day referencing is getting
the value of that integer
once again b i can be written as
asterisk b plus i b
is a pointer to one dimensional array of
three integers so b
plus i will also return a pointer to one
dimensional array of three integers and
dereferencing this particular day
referencing
will give us the one-dimensional array
and the name of one-dimensional array
returns us
pointer to the first element in the
array so this once again will be
pointer to integer by now if you clearly
understand how all the pointer
arithmetic
and dereferencing is happening in these
expressions
then it's not very difficult to
understand how things will be
for say a three-dimensional array
now let's say we have created a
three-dimensional array
named c we have an array of three cross
two cross two a three-dimensional array
is basically
an array or collection of
two-dimensional arrays
so if i have to show c in memory i will
show it something like this
i have assumed that the starting address
of c is byte addressed
800 the first 16 bytes starting address
800 is my first two dimensional array
i am assuming that each integer will
take four bytes
so all these cells in yellow are part of
the first two dimensional array
the next block of 16 bytes starting
address
816 is c1 and the next block of 16 bytes
starting at 32 is c2 we can further
break down the two dimensional arrays
into one dimensional arrays the first
two integers in c0
are part of the first one-dimensional
array c00
and 7 and 9 are part of c01
the first integer in c00 can be accessed
as c000
and we can go on like this okay once
again
i will play the same game i will write
some print statements
and you need to guess the output this
time
just using the array name c will give us
a pointer to a two dimensional
array of integers of size two cross two
so we can write a statement like this i
have declared
a pointer to two dimensional array of
integers
of size 2 cross 2 here the name of the
pointer is p
if i would just print p or c here
and i'm not writing the complete printf
statement once again
my output will be 800 now if
i will perform a d referencing and try
to
print asterisk c then this will be same
as
c 0 and c 0 is a 2 dimensional array
so we will get a pointer to the first
element in c0
all these expressions are returning us
pointer to one dimensional array of
integers
of size two and the address printed will
be
800 remember c is of type
pointer to 2d array of 2 cross 2 and
d referencing once is giving us pointer
to one dimensional array
of two integers c is returning us
pointer to two dimensional array of
integers c
itself is an array there is difference
between the two types
okay for c c i j
k where i j and k are some indices can
be written as
asterix of c i j plus
k and now once again we can write
c i j as asterisks of c i plus
j and the overall expression will look
something like this
and we can go ahead and write c i
as asterisks of c plus i
if you are able to understand how i have
derived these expressions if you are
able to understand all the
pointer arithmetic and dereferencing in
these expressions
then you are good working with
multi-dimensional arrays using pointers
i want a quick answer for this one what
will be
the output for this print statement
well c01 means we are going to this
one dimensional array that has these two
elements seven and nine
and when we are using the array name c01
we are getting a pointer
to first integer in this one-dimensional
array
pointer to this integer seven adding one
we are doing
pointer arithmetic to an integer pointer
so we will go to
nine and day referencing will give us
integer nine in fact this expression is
same as
c of zero one one now what will be the
output for this print statement
asterisks of c1 plus one c1 will return
us a pointer to one dimensional array
the first one-dimensional array in c1
this block containing integers three and
four
adding one is performing pointer
arithmetic and going to the next
one-dimensional array
it's going to this one-dimensional array
containing
six and one and now d-referencing is
basically
getting the one-dimensional array from
the pointer
and if you just use the name of the
one-dimensional array
you get a pointer to the first element
in one-dimensional array
so we will get a pointer to this integer
six
output will be 824.
this block of 4 bytes storing address
storing integer 3 is 816 next would be
next will be a 20 and next will be 8 24.
we can try out these expressions in real
program
i'm writing this simple c program i have
created this
three-dimensional array c the data
filled in
is same as we were showing in the
example in the first printf statement
i'm writing i'm trying to print
c asterisk c c 0 and ampersand c
0 0 all of these are pointers and
if i would just use person d
address would be printed when i'm
running this code as you can see
the output for all these four
expressions
is same any guesses for what will be the
output for this printf
statement this expression is nothing but
c001
the output for first printf is different
because this is a different
run of the program and in each run
the signed address would change but
whatever the address says it will be
same for these
four expressions i would recommend
trying out all the different expressions
that we were decoding earlier in a real
program like this
okay the next thing that i want to talk
about is passing multi-dimensional
arrays as function arguments
i'm going to declare a function and
let's name this function
f u n c and
i want this function to accept a
three-dimensional array as argument
so what do i do if i wanted a one
dimensional arrays argument
i could have given something like this
but
as we had discussed in one of our
previous lessons this syntax
is only a syntactical sugar it is
interpreted
like this by the compiler a fresh copy
of
array is not created for a function call
only a reference to it
in the form of a pointer is created
so now if in the main function i have an
array
a one-dimensional array like this and
let's say
the return type of this function is void
i can make a function called passing
a like this and this will be fine
now let's say we declare a two
dimensional array of two cross
three and now we want this function to
receive
to take a two dimensional array as
argument
now as we had discussed a will
return us pointer to integer but b
will return us a pointer to array of
three integers
one dimensional array of three integers
for this particular definition of p
so for the function to take this array
b as argument definition should be
something like this the argument should
be something like this
either we can write this or we can write
something like this only the first
dimension can be left empty the other
dimension has to be specified
and now i can pass b there is something
interesting here if i would declare a
two dimensional array something like
this let's say i declare a two
dimensional array
x of two cross four now i cannot
pass x to the function because
x will return pointer to one dimensional
array of four integers
while this function is supposed to
receive one dimensional array of three
integers
if x is defined something like this of
dimension five cross
three then passing x is fine
now if we want to pass this three
dimensional array
then once again we need to see what
pointer type c
will return so c will basically return
a pointer to two dimensional array of
two cross
two so we can either use a syntax like
this
or something like this and then we can
pass c
so this is how things will be for any
multi-dimensional
array except the first dimension
all other dimensions will be enforced
one common mistake that people do is for
a two-dimensional array
they try to use pointer to pointer
something like this
and for a three-dimensional array they
try to use something like this
which just won't work so this is pretty
much what we wanted to talk about
pointers and multi-dimensional arrays
thanks for watching
memory is one important
and crucial resource on our machine and
it is always good to know the
architecture of
memory the way operating system manages
memory
and the way a memory is accessible to us
as programmers
in this lesson we will discuss the
concept of dynamic memory
and we will see how to work with dynamic
memory using c or c
plus plus the memory that is assigned
to a program or application in a typical
architecture can be divided into
four segments one segment of the memory
is assigned to store the
instructions that need to be executed
another section stores all the static or
global variables the variables that are
not declared inside a function
and that have the whole lifetime of an
application they are
accessible anywhere during the whole
life cycle of the application as long as
the application is running
one section of the memory is used to
store all the information
of function calls and all the local
variables
and we have also talked about stack in
our lesson on
call by reference local variables are
declared
inside a function and they live only
till the time the function is executing
the amount of memory set aside for these
three segments
the text segment the global variable
segment and the stack
does not grow while the application is
running we will come back to why we use
this
fourth segment heap in a while let us
first understand how
these three segments of the memory are
used when a program
executes i have a simple c program here
we have a function square that gives me
the square of a number
we have another function square of sum
that is given two arguments
x and y and it returns us the square of
x plus y and in the main method i'm just
calling this function
square of sum passing it to arguments a
and b let us now see what happens in the
memory when
this program executes let us say this
rectangle
in green here is memory reserved as
stack and this rectangle in orange is
the memory reserved as
static or global variable section when
the program starts executing first the
main method is
invoked when the main method is invoked
some amount of memory
from the stack is allocated for
execution of
main and this total is a global variable
so it should
sit in this section the amount of memory
allocated on stack for execution of main
can also be called the stack
frame for the method main all the local
variables
arguments and the information where this
function should
should return back to all this
information is stored
within this stack frame the size of the
stack frame
for a method is calculated when the
program is compiling
now when main calls square of sum method
let's write shortcut s o s
for square of sum then a stack frame is
allocated for
the call to square of sum all these
local variables xyz will sit in this
particular stack frame
now sum of square calls square let's
again put a shortcut here for square
so another stack frame for square and it
will have its own local variables
at any time during the execution of the
program the function at the top of the
stack is executing and rest
are kind of paused waiting for the
function above to return something
and then it will resume execution i have
drawn this
play and pause button here in case you
do not understand
okay so this total is a global variable
it sits here
in this section global variable because
it is not declaring
declared inside a function we can access
it anywhere
and then we go to this particular
statement where we call square of sum
and square of sum is calling square
so right now this is our call stack
this program may not be the best way to
implement this logic
i have written this program this way so
that i can have some nested methods
calling each other let's say right now
we are at this particular statement we
are executing
executing this statement so at this
stage cost
a call stack will have these three
methods
now when this method finishes we will
return back to this particular statement
as soon as square function will return
it will be cleared from the stack memory
and now
some square of sum function will resume
once again when square of sum finishes
the control will
come back to this particular line to
line total is equal to square of sum
and main will resume again
now main will call printf so
once again printf will go to the top of
the stack
printf will finish and the control will
come back again to main and now main
will finish
and when main finishes program will also
finish
so in the end our global variables will
also get cleared
there was no need in this program to
keep this variable total as global
we should assign a variable as global
only if
it is needed at multiple places in
multiple functions and it is needed for
the whole lifetime of the
program otherwise it's a waste of memory
to keep it
keep available for the whole lifetime of
program execution
we had kept one global variable in this
program just to
understand the cost concepts here i must
point out
one more thing when our program starts
our
operating system allocates some amount
of reserved space let's say
os allocates 1 mb of space
as stack but the actual allocation of
the stack frame
and the actual allocation of the local
variables happens from this stack
during runtime and if our call stack
grows beyond the reserved memory for the
stack like
for example if a method a calls b b call
c and we go on calling
and we exhaust the whole space reserved
for the stack
then this is called stack overflow and
in this case
our program will crash
one common case of stack overflow is
when you write a bad recursion and your
program
goes infinitely into recursion
so as we can see there are some
limitations of stack
the memory set aside for stack does not
grow
during runtime application cannot
request more memory for stack
so if it is 1 mb then if the allocation
of variables and functions in stack
exceeds 1 mb
our program will crash further the
allocation and deallocation of memory
onto the stack happens by a set rule
when a function is called
it is pushed onto the stack on top of
the stack
when it finishes it is popped or removed
from the stack
it is not possible to manipulate the
scope of a variable
if it is on the stack another limitation
is that if we need to declare a large
data type
like an array as local variable then we
need to know the size of the array
at compile time only if we have a
scenario like
we want to decide how large the array
will be based on some parameter
during runtime then it is a problem with
stack
for all these requirements like
allocating large
chunks of memory or keeping a variable
in the memory till the time we want
we have heap
unlike stack applications heap
is not fixed its size can vary during
the lifetime of the application
and there is no set rule for allocation
and deallocation of memory
a programmer can totally control how
much memory
to use from the heap till what time to
keep the data
in the memory during the application's
lifetime
and heap can grow as long as you do not
run out of memory
on the system itself that is a dangerous
thing also and we need to be really
careful
about using heap for this reason we also
sometimes call
heap free pool of memory or free
store of memory we can get as much as we
want from the heap
how heap is implemented by the operating
system
language runtime or the compiler is
something which can vary which is a
thing of
computer architecture but an abstracted
way
of looking at the heap as a programmer
is that this is one large
free pool of memory available to us that
we can use
flexibly as per our need
heap is also called dynamic memory and
using the heap is referred to as dynamic
memory allocation
and let us now see how to use the heap
in our
c or c plus plus program i will clear
this code in the left
and i will draw one more rectangular
block here
for heap there is one more thing that i
must point out before moving forward
heap is also one data structure and if
you do not know about this data
structure heap yet
you will learn about it in your data
structure course but this nomenclature
here
has nothing to do with the heap data
structure
the term heap here is being used only
for the
large free pool of memory heap data
structure does not come anywhere in this
con
context this term often confuses a lot
of people when they
know about heap data structure stack is
also one data structure but
the stack segment of the memory is
actually an implementation of stack data
structure
but heap is not an implementation of
heap data structure
to use dynamic memory in c we need to
know about
four functions malloc catalog
re-alloc and free to use dynamic memory
in c plus plus we need to know about two
operators
new and delete these four functions
can also be used in c plus because
c plus plus has backward compatibility
it is only a
super set of c but c plus plus
programmers mostly
use these two operators new and delete
we will see some code examples
and try to understand how things happen
when dynamic memory is used
let us first pick up some code example
in c
let us write a c program i'll clean up
some of this stuff in the right
one mb first tag this was just an
assumption in reality the size of the
stack will be decided by the operating
system
and the compiler it is a thing of
architecture
coming back to the code if we declare a
variable like this
then this variable is a local variable
it goes on the stack
memory for this particular variable a
will be allocated from the stack frame
of the
main method let us say we want to
store an integer on the heap to reserve
or get some space allocated on the heap
we need to call the malloc function
something like this the malloc function
asks for
how much memory to allocate on the heap
in bytes
when we say malloc and passes pass as
argument size of integer
then we are saying that hey give me a
block of memory which is
four bytes four bytes is the typical
size of an integer
so one block of four bytes will be
reserved or allocated on the heap
and malloc will return a pointer to the
starting address of this block
and malloc returns a void pointer let us
say the starting address of this block
of 4 bytes is 200
so malloc will return us the address
200. now we have a pointer to integer p
which is a local variable to main so
this will be uh
this will be allocated in the stack
frame of the main method
we have done a type casting here because
malloc returns pointer to
wide sorry void pointer and p is an
integer pointer
now p stores the address of this block
of memory which is
200 so we have got some block of memory
on the heap
which we want to use to store an integer
right now we do not know what's there in
this particular
block of memory if we want to fill in
something here
we need to de-reference this location
using the pointer p
and then put in some value in fact the
only way to use
memory on heap is through reference all
the malloc function does is
looks for some free space in the heap
books it or reserves it for you
and give back the pointer and the only
way you can access this particular block
by keeping a pointer variable which will
be local to your
function now let us write something like
this
after writing 10 in this particular
block
i will go ahead and make one more call
to malloc
when i make one more call to malloc one
more block of
four bytes is allocated on the heap and
let us say the address is
400 for this block now the address that
is returned by the second call to malloc
we store this address in the variable p
so what happens
is that p is now pointing to the address
400
the next line writes 20 at this address
we allocated one more block and we
modified the address and p to
point to this block the previous block
will still sit in the heap
this memory we are still consuming it
will not be cleared off automatically
at any point in our program if we are
done using some particular block
of memory which is dynamically allocated
using malloc
we also need to clear it because it is
unnecessary consumption of memory which
is an important resource
so what we should have done here is that
once we were done using this particular
block of memory at 200
we should have made a call to the
function free
any memory which is allocated using
malloc is cleared off
by calling free and to free we pass the
pointer to the starting address of the
memory block
so now with this code this first block
of memory will first be cleared
and then we will be pointing to another
memory address
it is the responsibility of the
programmer to clear anything
on the heap if he has allocated it and
does not need it any further
so if you see in terms of the scope of
the variable anything allocated on the
heap
is not automatically deallocated when
the function completes like
on the stack and it does not live it
does not need to live
for the whole lifetime of the
application like a global variable
we can control when to free anything on
the heap when to deallocate anything on
the heap
if we wanted to store an array on the
heap like let's say we wanted to store
an integer array
then all we do is make a call to the
malloc asking for
one block of memory equal to the total
size of the array in bytes
so if we want an integer array of
20 elements then we will make a call to
malloc
asking 20 into size of int which will be
4
number of bytes so what will happen now
is that one big contiguous block of
memory
for 20 integers will be allocated on the
heap
and we will get the starting address of
this block so we kind of get the base
address
of the array this p will point here
to the base address of this block and
then in our code we can use this
20 integers as p0 p1
p2 and so on as we know
p0 is same as saying value at address p
and p1 is same as saying value at
address p
plus 1 this is what it means
one more thing if malloc is not able to
find any free block of memory
is not able to allocate some memory on
the heap it returns
null so for error handling we need to
know this
and we need to write our code
appropriately
malloc and free the use of malloc and
free is c style code
if we want to write the same code same
logic in c plus plus then there is not
much difference
instead of using these two functions
malloc and free
we will use two operators new and delete
and write our code something like this
so instead of using malloc we are using
the new operator here
and instead of using free we are using
delete here
if we want to allocate an array we
use something like this where we put the
size in brackets here
and if we want to free an array we use
this particular operator delete
and two brackets sorry one bracket
with c plus plus we do not have to do
all these type castings
like malloc returns void and we need to
type cast it back to integer pointer
new and delete operators are type safe
what it means is that
they're used with a type and return
pointers to
a particular type only so here we will
get a pointer to
integer only we will be talking about
dynamic memory allocation
and other library functions in more
detail in the coming lessons
so thanks for watching in our previous
lesson we learned the concept of
dynamic memory allocation we learnt
about
stack and heap in the context of
applications memory
in this lesson we will be looking at
various library functions available
in c for dynamic memory allocation we
will
look through these functions in some
code examples
we will be talking about three functions
that allocate
block of memory on the heap and these
functions are
malloc catalog and
reallock and we will also be talking
about one function that
d allocates a block of memory on the
heap
and this function is free now let us
first talk about malloc
this is the most frequently used library
function
for dynamic memory allocation and the
signature or the definition of this
function is
something like this this function as
argument asks you for the size of the
memory block in
bytes this data type size underscore t
if you are not aware of it is a data
type that stores
only positive integer values so you can
think of this particular data type as
unsigned
integer data type the size cannot be a
negative value it cannot
either be 0 or a positive value and
to force this kind of behavior we use
this particular type
and this function malloc returns a void
pointer
we have talked about void pointer in our
previous lessons
malloc returns a void pointer that gives
us the address of the first
byte in this block the block of memory
that it allocates
so using malloc you kind of say that hey
give me a block of
memory with these many bytes let us say
what we have here in the right is the
heap section of memory available to us
each of these partitions are one byte as
we know each byte in the memory has an
address
let us say this bottom most byte has the
address two zero zero
and the next byte is two zero one and we
go on increasing towards the top
i'll mark these and mark the address of
some of these bytes
let's say in our code we make a call to
malloc something like this
that hey give me a block of memory that
is
4 bytes let's say we store the address
returned by malloc
in a void pointer variable now let's
assume that this particular
rectangular block that we are showing
here in the red is what gets
allocated against this call to malloc
these are four bytes the starting
address is 208
so what will be the address in p if we
want to print
the address in p then what will be the
output the output will be 208
this is cool using malloc we are able to
allocate some amount of memory reserve
some amount of memory
but why do we reserve memory we reserve
our allocate memory because we want to
store some data there
so we do not want to just randomly
allocate some number of bytes
so all that is correct to write a
statement like this in practice we would
not do so
in practice we would first calculate how
much amount of memory
we need to store our data so let's say
we want to store
an integer just one integer so i need
a memory block equal to the size of one
integer
so we typically use the function size
off
which returns us the size of a variable
in bytes
to figure out the size of the data type
and then we typically multiply this
particular value
returned by size off by the number of
units that we need
so if we need just one integer
if we need memory for just one integer
and this is good
if we need memory for 10 integers we
would write something like this
give me 10 into sizeof integer
integer is a primitive data type
sometimes you may know that i know that
size of integer is 4 bytes
so i can write something like 10 into 4
here but it's not a good practice to do
so
size of a variable depends upon the
compiler and we would also be
using malloc to allocate memory for
complex data types
so we must use malloc like this
total number of bytes should be written
as number of elements into
size of one unit one unit of the data
let's say we want to have space for
three integers
i have picked up three so that i have
enough enough space
to allocate memory in the figure that
i'm showing here
and let's say and this block of 12 bytes
is allocated because size of integer is
four bytes
typically so this starting address would
be 201
now how do we fill in data here if you
see malloc returns a void pointer
and void pointer as such cannot be
dereferenced
you cannot write a statement something
like asterisk p is equal to 2
this is incorrect you cannot dereference
a void pointer white pointer in fact is
only used as a generic pointer type
which is normally type casted into a
pointer type of a particular
data type and then it is used because
malloc itself is a generic function to
allocate
some number of bytes in memory in heap
it does not care where whether you are
allocating this memory to store
character or
to store integer or to store any other
data type
it simply returns a void pointer to the
starting address
to be able to use this block of memory
we first need to typecast this void
pointer
into a pointer of some data type so here
we will write something like
in star p instead of picking up a void
pointer we pick up
a pointer to integer because we want to
operate with integers
so to d reference we need an integer
pointer type so
we do the type casting here of the void
pointer and now this statement is valid
if we want to assign some value to the
second element second integer in this
list
then we will do something like we will
de-difference the address p plus one
let's say we write the value four here
and if we want to
access the third integer then we will
write something like this
let's say the value of six here by
asking for a memory block
for three integers we are basically
creating an array of integers
with three elements we could also write
this asterisk p
as p zero and we could also write
asterisk p
plus one as p p1 and similarly asterisk
p plus 2 as p2
they mean the same all the manipulation
on dynamically allocated memory happens
through pointers
you have a pointer to the starting
address and then if you want to go to
the next
element in the array you increment the
pointer
and this is how things happen we have
two more functions that allocate block
of memory
let us now talk about calloc the
signature or definition of kellogg
is something like this kellogg also does
the same stuff as malloc
it is only a slightly different kellogg
also returns
a void pointer but kellogg takes two
arguments
instead of one argument it takes two
arguments the first argument is the
number of elements
of a particular data type and the second
argument is the size of the data type
so with malloc if we have to declare an
array of size three
an integer area of size 3 we would say 3
into size of
end with callout we would say something
like this
the first argument is how many units of
the data type you want
or the number of elements and the second
argument is the size of data type in
bytes there is one more difference
between malloc and calloc
when malloc allocates some amount of
memory it does not initialize the bytes
with
any value so if you do not fill in any
value into these
addresses allocated by malloc you would
have some garbage there
but if you allocate memory through
callock calloc
sets all byte positions with value
zero so it also initializes the memory
that it allocates
to zero the third function that we
want to talk about is reallock
if you have a block of memory
dynamically
allocated block of memory and if you
want to change the size of this block of
memory
then you can use real lock the
definition or the signature of this
particular function is
this function takes two arguments the
first argument is
pointed to the starting address of the
existing
block and the second argument is
the size of the new block there can be a
couple of cases in real lock
the size of the new block that we want
may be
larger than than the size of the
previous block in that case
machine may create an entirely new block
and copy the previous data
whatever bytes was written in the
previous block into the new block
if contiguous or consecutive memory is
already available
with the existing block and the existing
block may also be extended
let us now look at some code examples
and see what we can do
with these three functions and we will
discuss the
function free in our code itself
i'll write some c code and look at some
of the use cases in which
we can use dynamic memory allocation the
first use case is
let us say we want to declare an array
and we want to first ask the user the
size of the array and then we want to
declare an array
exactly of this particular size entered
by the user so let's say i have a
variable
n and i write a print statement like
enter size of array and then i input
this
number n from the console now i want to
declare an array of size
n only so can i do something like this
well no this particular value in the
braces
cannot be a variable this will give you
compilation error
we need to know the size of the array we
cannot know the size of the array during
runtime
in such a scenario we can allocate the
memory dynamically so we will write
something like
in star a is equal to and we will make a
call to malloc
to allocate a memory block
equal to the size of n integers
and this will again give a compilation
error unless we
type cast this particular return of
malloc to integer pointer
and now we have an array of size n and
we can
fill in some data into these dynamically
into the elements of this dynamically
allocated array
let's say we want to put data something
like first element is
1 and the second element is 2 and so on
so we'll write something like a i is
equal to i plus 1.
we can print the elements in the array
let's say we want to pick up size of
array as
10 okay so the output is as expected
we have 10 elements from 1 to 10
if i give size of error as let's say 25
then this is what we get we get all the
elements still 25
if we wanted to use catalog instead of
malloc here
the only change in this code would be
that we would use catalog here and we
would have two arguments
n would separate out as first argument
and the second argument would be size of
end
and this program will run seamlessly
there is one more difference between
malloc and callock
if we do not use this initialization
then with catalog as you can see all the
elements are being printed
as zero they are all initialized to zero
but if we were using malloc here
then these elements are not initialized
there is some garbage value at each of
these indices in the array
so this is one difference between malloc
and catalog calloc initializes
fills the value 0 into each byte while
malloc
doesn't do this initialization i'll
rewrite this initialization loop again
and now we will talk about free
any memory that is dynamically allocated
remains allocated till the lifetime of
the program
till the time the program is executing
unless you explicitly
de-allocate and to deallocate memory
allocated using malloc or catalog or
real lock
we have the function free and to the
function free you just pass
the starting address of the memory block
as argument
now what will happen if i free a if we
free a then the data from that memory
is erased it may or may not be erased it
actually depends upon your
compiler or machine but that memory will
be available for a location against
another call to malloc
let's say let's see what happens in this
case when we are printing after freeing
that particular memory block
i give error sizes 5 and as you can see
the elements being printed here
there is some garbage value being
printed if this free was not there
we would have printed elements 1 2 3 4 5
as initialized
now the obvious question would be even
though we are freeing the memory here
we are able to access that the value at
that particular memory location using
this statement
when we are using a i the element at
index i well that is one dangerous thing
about pointers
if you know the address you can look at
the value at that address
but you should read and write to that
address only if that address is
allocated to you
what if that address is not allocated to
you like in this case
well you do not know what you are
reading or what you are writing
and what behavior it will have it
actually depends upon the compiler and
the machine
in my case let's say after freeing we
try to access
the third element a2 and try to push
some value there
let's see what happens if we run this
program let's give size of arrays 5
again
if you see even after free we are able
to modify
the value at this particular address a2
but on some machine
such a program may cause our program to
crash
we should always be sure to use the
memory that is allocated
otherwise it's like shooting in the dark
we do not know what will happen
we will now talk about re-unlock if we
want to modify the size of a memory
block
let's say we have a memory block to
store n elements in an array
and we want to extend it to maybe we
want to double the size of the array
or maybe we want to reduce the size of
the array to half
for such scenario we use real lock and
call to real lock will be something like
this
let's say we take another pointer
variable b
then to reallock we pass the previous
pointer a
and size of the new block so the new
block is 2 into n
into sizeof hint and will of course to
of course do the
typecasting here ok now what this call
will do
is it will create a new memory block of
size 2n
and copy the values in the previous
block in the previous memory block a
into this new memory block how real lock
works
is that if the size of the new block is
greater than the size of the previous
block
then if it is possible to extend the
previous block find some consecutive
memory with the same block
then the previous block itself is
extended else
a new block is allocated and the
previous block the content from the
previous block is copied
and the previous block is deallocated
this will become further clear
if i write this print statement i'll
print the previous block address
stored in a and the new address stored
in b and i'll also print
all the 2n elements in b now
and i'll print each element in the array
b in one single line
let's say size of there is 5 again okay
so the previous block address is
9920128 and if you see the new address
is also same
so it was possible to extend the
previous block only
and in b the first five elements are
from a and rest five elements are
garbage value
if we wanted to reduce the array size to
let's say half
ah then the same block the previous
block itself will be reduced
so let's say i want to print the
previous block now the n elements
now as you can see the first two
elements are copied one and two
they're not copied in fact they're there
already the rest three are deallocated
when we divide five by two we take only
the integral part
so we kind of deallocate the space for
three elements here
in fact if we give the size to be zero
here
all that will happen is that the
complete block for a will be deallocated
so this statement will be equivalent to
using free upon a
in most cases we will put the return
address by real lock into the same
integer pointer
so we can write instead of writing b
here we can write a also
we can also pass the first argument to
real log as
null if the first argument is null and
the second argument is size
and let's say we want to create
something like
a new block with address starting at a
store in b
then if the first argument is null then
this
is equivalent to calling a malloc
this only creates a new block does not
copy anything from the previous block
so real lock can be used with the right
arguments as substitute for free as well
as
as substitute for malloc this was all
about malloc
allocary unlock and free we will see
more code on dynamic memory allocation
in the coming lessons
so thanks for watching in this lesson we
will talk about
pointers as return types for functions
a pointer is just another data type
it's just that a pointer stores the
address of another data type
so it is quite possible for a function
to return pointer
but we must understand the use cases in
which we may want to return a pointer
from a function
so let us try to understand this i'll
get started by
writing some code now i want to write a
very simple c program initially
i want to write a function add that will
take
two integers as argument and sum these
two numbers and return the sum
so let's say we declare another variable
c
and c is equal to a plus b and the
function returns c
now in the main method i'll initialize
two variables let's name these variables
x
and y let's say x is equal to 2 and y is
equal to
4 and we will have another variable z
which will be the return of this
function add and we will pass
x and y as arguments to this function
and finally i'll print something like
sum is equal to z no prices for guessing
the output here i'll modify this code
slightly
but before that i want to talk about
this concept
once again that x y and z
are local variables to main function
and a b and c are local to add function
and what really happens when we call the
add function is that
value in this variable x of main is
copied to
variable a of add and value
in y of main is copied to b of add
and what if we name these variables in
main
a b and c instead of x y and z
if we run this code output will be the
same this time what we will say
is that the value in a of main is copied
to a of
add and the value in b of main is copied
to b of
add this a in main and this a in add
they are not the same you can verify
this by printing something like this
i'm printing the addresses of these two
a's
in my code and as you can see address of
a
in main is something like 2883032 and
in add it is 288 2792 so they are not
the same
that means these variables are not the
same they are different memory addresses
the names of variables are local or
specific to a particular function
in our example here the method the
function main
can be called calling function and the
function
add can be called called function
in this particular call when we are
saying that c is equal to
add and passing a and b and this call
where a
and b in main are getting copied to a
and b in add
this is called a call by value
this can be called a call by value now
what i want to do is
instead of passing by value i want to
pass the addresses of these two
variables
so i want to say that i want to pass
address of a
and address of b to the add function so
the signature of add function should be
such that it should
receive the addresses so i'll say that
okay it takes two pointer two integers
a and b and now we can
access the values at these addresses
by using this asterisk operator which is
used to dereference
an address now such a call is called
call by reference
a and b are integers local to main
function and in the function
add a and b are not integer variables a
and b
are pointer variables pointer to
integers
so uh their type is different they are
not int they are in
star but at the end of the day they are
also variables which are local to
the function add it's just that they're
not integers
and now i'm using these two variables
which are pointer to integers
to access these two variables a
and b in the main method and to do so we
use the asterisk operator and now this
code should also work
i'll write a few more print statements
inside this function
add i have tried to print
a and i have tried to print asterisk a
and initially i was printing ampersand a
so now ampersand a should give us the
address of the pointer variable
a should give us the address of a in
main because that is what
this variable stores and asterisk a
should give us the value
of a in main let us see in the output
as you can see here the address of a in
main is 3537612
and address of a in add is something
else but the value in a of add
which is the address of a of main is
equal to three five three seven six two
so the first and the third line are same
and using the address we are printing
the value which is equal to two
i had a spell mistake here
now i'll clean up some of these print
statements
coming back to our function add we are
returning this value c
and once again in the main method we are
collecting this values seeing another
variable which is c
of main why not do something like pass
the address of this c
in add function so what we will do now
is we will say that we want to return a
pointer to integer from this function
and here we will return ampersand c now
ampersand operator when it is put in
front of a variable it gives us the
address
now of course here we will have to
collect
this particular address so we will have
to define a pointer variable
now this would be okay and when we are
printing we will have to print the value
at address being pointed to by this
pointer variable
so what we just did was now what we just
did is we modified this
add function to return a pointer to
integer
there are two syntax we can say in and
then
put this asterisk sign or we can say int
and then put this asterisk sign in front
of the
function name add and both the syntax
are valid now this function is returning
pointer to
integer let us run this program and see
what happens
well let me also strike of this print
statement here
okay so the output seems to be all right
now have you got some logical error with
this code already
if you haven't stay with me for some
time
now what i want to do is i want to write
another function
a simple function that will print hello
world so i'll name this function print
hello world and then this function i'll
write a simple print statement
and now before i print this sum what
i'll do is
i'll call this function print hello
world
and let's see what happens now oops this
looks weird
some is not correct now i just saw that
it was coming fine in my last run when i
did not
call this print hello world what
happened
so let's try to understand what really
happened here
i'll come back to this familiar diagram
of various sections
of applications memory and the memory
that is allocated to a program is
typically
divided into these sections all the
local variables
and the information about function call
executions goes into
the stack so let us run through this
code let us simulate this code and see
what's really happening in the memory
for each function call some part of the
memory from the stack
is allocated for its execution we call
this the stack frame of that method
or that function when the program starts
executing first
the main method is invoked so in the
stack frame
some memory will be allocated for main
function and all the local variables of
main function will live
inside this stack frame let's say the
starting address of this stack frame is
100 and the end address of this stack
frame is
130 and we will have three local
variables created here
a b and pt are a and b are integers and
ptr is an
integer pointer let's say is at address
100 b
is at address 112 and ptr is at address
120 i'm just making these assumptions
now when the main method will come at
this line will where it is calling
add function its execution will pause
and now memory will be allocated for the
execution of
add at any time whatever function is at
the top of stack
is executing main method will wait for
add function to complete and return so
here i should say a is equal to 2 b is
equal to 4
and now add comes here in the stack
let's say add gets
memory from 130 to 160 and add also has
three local variables a b
and c a and b are pointers to integers
the value of a will be 100 and the value
of b
will be 112. let's say their addresses
is
addresses are 130 140
and 144
once again these are just random
assumptions now c
is calculated as asterisk a plus
asterisk b
a is pointing to this location and b
is pointing to this location asterisk is
value at
address stored in a and asterisk b is
value at address stored in b so this c
will be
six here these two values will be added
now this add function will return the
address of its local variable c
which is 144 and finish its execution so
this ptr will be 144
and now the memory that is allocated to
add function
will be deallocated now this memory
above address 130
can be used for other function calls
and even though this variable pointer
ptr
stores the address 144 stores the
address of this particular block
it kind of points to this particular
block the data here is not guaranteed
because this memory has been deallocated
now we come here to this print hello
world and now
a memory from stack will be allocated
for print hello world
above this stack frame of main method
this is main
so let's say that print hello world gets
this memory block
from address 130 to address 150.
now there is no local variable in this
print hello world function
but still function call execution
involves storage of some information so
now this section from 130 to 150
is for print hello world i'll write phws
shortcut for print hello world
and it has been overwritten so this
block at 144
no more stores value six so when we come
here
at this print statement to print the
value
at this particular address we get some
garbage value now the obvious question
would be why did the
why did we get the right value when we
were not making a call to print hello
world
i would say that i just got lucky maybe
because i did not call any other
function
after making a call to add my machine
did not overwrite or erase the data at
that particular memory location
but when i made a call to print hello
world that memory got used
if you see we have passed the addresses
of these two variables a
and b of main to add function but that
is all right because
called function always comes above the
calling function in the stack so anytime
this called function is executing
calling function will be in the memory
so if add is executing
main is guaranteed to be in the memory
so addresses of variables in main will
be accessible to add
but if we try to return a local variable
from the called function
back to the calling function like if we
want to return a local variable from add
to main
then when that function finishes and the
control returns back to the calling
function
that memory has already been deallocated
so it is okay to pass something
from bottom to top in this call stack or
i should rather say that
it's okay to pass a local variable the
address of a local variable
from bottom to top in this stack but it
is not okay to
return the address of a local variable
from top to bottom in the stack
in the call stack i hope this makes
sense so now the obvious question would
be what are the use cases in which
we may want to return pointers from
functions
well if we have address of some memory
block in the heap section or some memory
block in the global section
then we can safely return the address of
these blocks because
anything in the heap has to be
explicitly deallocated we control
its deallocation unlike stack and
anything which is in the global
section a global variable lives for the
entire lifetime of the program
i can use malloc or new operator in c
plus to get some memory on heap so if i
modify my code something like this
i will declare this c as a pointer to
integer
and get some space allocated on the
heap using a call to malloc
now malloc is a library function that
returns pointer
but it returns pointer to an address
which is on the heap
so we get a memory block and using this
pointer variable now
we can write this value asterisk a plus
asterisk
b at that particular memory block and
then we can return this address c
which is the same address that malloc
returned us
but we are safe now because we are
returning address of
a block which is on the heap and uh and
not on the stack
and this will work now now in this code
let's say this call to malloc gives us
this block at address 500 in the heap
c now is only pointing to this block and
using c we have written this
data here this value 6 and now when add
finishes
the address returned by the add function
which is
address 500 is still valid and we still
have the data there
and it will not be deallocated anything
on the heap is explicitly has to be
explicitly deallocated
so while returning pointers from
functions we need to be careful about
the scope
we must be sure that the address is not
reused to store something else
or the data is not cleared from that
address in most cases we will be
returning pointers to memory that is
allocated on the heap
or memory that is in the global section
the global variable section
in our coming lessons one place where we
will be using
pointers as function returns in our code
is implementation of
linked list data structure so this was
pointers
as function returns thanks for watching
in this lesson we are going to talk
about function pointers
function pointers as the name suggests
are used to store address of functions
so far we have used pointers mostly as
variables that would store
address of other variables basically
pointers are data types that can be used
to
store the address of some data stored in
computers memory or in other words
to point to or refer to some data and it
doesn't always have to be a variable
data could be stored as constant also
and we use pointers not just to store
the address
we can dereference and get the value at
whatever address the pointer is pointing
to
now we are saying that we can have
pointers that can store
address of functions or in other words
can point to functions
and we can use a pointer to function to
dereference
and execute the function and this is
really interesting
some basic questions would pop up what
really would be
the address of a function and even if we
can have pointers to functions
what are the use cases in which we may
want to have them
there are really interesting use cases
of function pointers but we will talk
about them later
let's first try to understand the core
logic here
once again i have drawn this familiar
diagram the memory that is
allocated to an application or a program
can typically be divided into these four
segments
we have talked about this quite a bit in
our previous lessons
okay now a program is basically a set or
sequence of instructions
that you would give to the computer to
perform a task
we can write our program in a high level
language like c
or c plus plus but at lowest level in
its architecture
computer understands and executes only
binary
any instruction that has to be executed
by the computer has
to be encoded in binary of course there
will be some rules
for encoding so what we do is we
write our program or set of instructions
in a high level language like c
or c plus plus and we pass it to a
program
called compiler as input and
corresponding to
the source code compiler generates what
we call
machine code or executable code
which is instructions encoded in binary
something like what i'm trying to show
here compiler basically takes
one or more source files let's say the
program that i have written here
is in a file named program.c
now a compiler for c language will take
this file as
input and create an executable file
that will have the machine code on a
windows machine executable file has
extension
exe an executable file will be stored in
disk drive
or some secondary storage device
whenever we say memory
just memory in context of programming we
mean
the random access memory or ram that we
also call the main memory
or primary storage so whatever
applications memory we are talking about
here will be
a chunk of main memory a program
or application gets a chunk of memory
only when it starts execution
when the application finishes execution
this memory is claimed
back what really happens is that when we
run a program when a program starts
execution
some amount of memory is allocated to it
and that is what we are calling
applications memory here the code or
text segment of applications memory
is basically the machine code or
instructions
copied from the executable file
instructions are not executed directly
from secondary storage
therefore they're first copied to main
memory
and then only they can be executed
during program execution we need memory
not just to store
instructions to be executed but also to
store
a lot of data that we would work upon
in a program these other segments are
mostly about
storing and managing data what i'm going
to do now is i'm going to zoom in to the
code or text
segment let's assume that each
instruction in machine language takes
4 bytes i'm trying to show the section
of memory storing the instructions here
each partition here is a block of 4
bytes and address is increasing from top
to bottom
so we have instruction 0 at address 200
and the next instruction is at address
204
and the next is at 208 and so on
instructions in a program are executed
sequentially
only exception will be when instruction
itself will say that hey
go to or jump to this other instruction
at this particular address which will
happen in case of
function calls for example if
instruction 0 1 at address 200 is
currently executing
by default the next instruction to be
executed
is instruction 0 2 at address 204
unless instruction 01 itself is
something like
go to instruction 05 at address 216
which will happen in case of function
calls a function
is nothing but a set of instructions
stored in one contiguous block of memory
let's say this block containing
instructions five till
8 is a function i'll name this function
fu and c1 basically a function is a set
of instructions to perform a subtask
in memory a function will be one
contiguous block
with some instructions the address of a
function what we also call
entry point of a function will be the
address of the first
instruction in the function in this
example here
address of function 1 is 216.
a function call in machine language will
basically be an instruction
to jump to entry point of some function
to jump to first instruction in a
function
now we will not go any deeper into
architecture now this is good enough to
understand function pointers
when we say function pointers store
address of functions
we basically mean that function pointers
stored
the starting address or entry point
of the block of memory containing all
the instructions in a function
let's now see how we can create and use
function pointers in a c
or c plus program i am going to write a
simple c
program here the first thing that i'm
going to do is i'm going to write a
function
named add that will take two integers as
argument
and return the sum of these two integers
and now i'm going to create a function
pointer that should point to this
function
add the syntax to create function
pointer is
first type in the return type of the
function to which this pointer will
point
add will return int so i typed in int
then after space within parenthesis type
in
asterix and then name of the variable
so i'm creating a pointer named p and
now
once again within parenthesis type in
all the argument types of the function
to which this pointer will point
argument types and function declaration
should be
exactly same as in the function to which
this pointer will point
because both the arguments in add
function are int
we have two ends in the declaration of
function pointer also to initialize
function pointer and fill in the address
of a function we can
use a statement like this as we know
ampersand operator gives us the address
of something
the statement p equal ampersand add
will fill in the address of add in p
so p now points to add and using
p we can execute this function add what
i'm going to do here is i'm going to
declare
an integer variable named c and now
i'm going to write a statement like this
what i've done here is
first i have used the asterisk operator
to dereference and get the function
and then i have passed arguments
just like i would do with a function
name so i've passed two integers two and
three
and if everything is all right the
output of this printf statement here
should be integer value 5. when i run
the program this is what i get
so this is really cool we just used a
function pointer to refer to a function
and then execute the function one thing
about the syntax of function pointer
declaration
we are putting the identifier or name of
the pointer within this
parenthesis if we would not use the
parenthesis
then it will mean that we are declaring
a function that will return pointer to
integer in this case
if i would write something like this i
would write a declaration
something like this then this is
declaring a function that would return
pointer to integer we can have an
asterisk just before the function
name or we can have an asterisk just
after int
these two syntax are same but if i would
put this
within parenthesis then this is
declaring a function pointer
okay few more things in this
initialization here we are using this
ampersand operator
even if we do not use this ampersand
operator
it will mean the same just using the
function name will also return us
address of the function or in other
words an appropriate pointer
to data friends instead of using this
parenthesis
and asterisk operator with function
pointer name we can simply use
the function pointer name and this is
good enough
so we can use function pointer name or
identifier just like function name
as you can see the output here is as
expected
so we have two possible syntax for both
referencing and data referencing
you can use whichever you like the
second one is more famous
one final thing to be able to point to a
function
type of the function pointer must be
appropriate so
in this declaration of p here if i would
change
it something like this then this
function pointer is
meant to point to a function that should
take two integers as argument
and should return void add function
is returning int so p cannot point to
add this will give me compilation error
once again if i will change the
declaration something like this if i
will have only one argument in the
declaration
of function pointer then p cannot point
to add
okay now let's use some more functions
with different signatures
and try to execute them through function
pointers i am writing this function
print hello
it will simply print hello on screen we
will have to declare
a function pointer like this
and then we can initialize the pointer
and fill in the address of this function
and now we can execute the function
through the pointer
let's see what the output is this looks
all right
now let's say we want to say hello to
someone
and i'll change the signature of print
hello to take a string as argument
the declaration of a function pointer
will also change
and while calling we will have to pass a
string
upon running this program this is what i
get and this is also looking fine
so this is pretty much how we can create
and use function
pointers in c or c plus function
pointers are used in a program in
interesting scenarios they have
interesting use cases
we will talk about the use cases in next
lesson this is it for this lesson
thanks for watching in our previous
lesson we saw what function pointers are
and then we wrote a simple program to
understand how we can
create function pointers in a c or c
plus
program but we did not discuss the real
use cases
of function pointers the real scenarios
where function pointers can be useful
so in this lesson we are going to talk
about the use cases of function pointers
all the use cases of function pointers
are around this concept
that function pointers can be passed as
arguments to functions and then a
function that would receive a function
pointer as
argument can call back the function
that this pointer will point to to
explain this better i will have to write
some code
first of all i am going to write a
simple function named
a this function takes no argument
but it turns void and simply prints
hello
on screen now i will write another
function
named p this function takes a function
pointer as argument
ptr should point to a function that
should take no argument
and should return void a function like
a now in b i will simply use this
function pointer ptr
to call whatever function it's pointing
to
or in other words i can say that i will
call back
the function pass to me or given to me
through ptr
in the main function i will declare a
function pointer
and this function pointer should also
point to a function
that should take no argument and should
return void i will initialize this
function pointer p with address of
a and now i will call this function b
passing it this function pointer p let's
run this program and see what happens
hello is getting printed on screen so
basically function a
is getting executed a is getting
executed through this callback
in the main function instead of writing
these two statements i can simply write
a statement like this and this should be
good enough because
name of a function we had discussed this
earlier also
returns a pointer so this one statement
is same as previous two statements
when reference to a function is passed
to another function
then that particular function is called
a callback function so
a is a callback function here it can be
called
back by b through the reference through
the function pointer
this statement where we are calling the
function through function pointer is
a callback we are still not doing
something very meaningful here
what's the point in calling a indirectly
through b
in this code this is not making much
sense
so let's now look at a scenario where
using a function pointer and callback
can make our life easier i have a simple
scenario
i have a list of integers in an array
and i want to sort this list
in increasing order of the value of
integers
to do so i will write my own sort
function
i am writing a function named sort that
will take an array
and number of elements in the array
the function will take an integer array
here i can
write a and then brackets or
i can write asterisk a these two are
alternate syntax
i will use simple bubble sort algorithm
i have renamed this function as bubble
sort
in bubble sort we make multiple passes
on an array
and in each pass as we go from left to
right as we go from lower indices to
higher indices
we compare adjacent elements and if the
element at lower index
is greater than the element at higher
index while comparing adjacent elements
then we swap the elements this inner
loop
is a pass on array and
this outer loop is basically saying that
we will make n passes
after first pass the largest element in
the list
will bubble up to the highest index
and in the next pass the second largest
will bubble up to its appropriate
position
this will go on and it finally in n
passes
the complete list will be sorted if you
want to refresh bubble sort
there is a link to my code school's
lesson on bubble sort in the description
of this video
in the main function i have called
bubble sort function passing it
array a and then i'm printing all the
elements in a and hopefully element
should be printed in
increasing order the output is as
expected we have a sorted list
here okay now let's say i want to sort
my list in decreasing order of the value
of integers
so what change should go in my code here
think about it
the only change will be in this
comparison logic
in this if statement while comparing the
adjacent elements now i will say that
if the element in left is smaller if the
element at lower index is smaller
then swap or basically then push it
towards
higher index comparing adjacent elements
and swapping
is basically pushing smallest or largest
element
towards higher indices with this
condition
with this comparison we are pushing the
smaller
number towards higher index let's see
the output now
as you can see i'm getting the numbers
in decreasing order now my list is
sorted
in decreasing order of the value of
integers
now let's say i have a requirement like
this
sometimes in my program i want to sort a
list of integers
in increasing order and sometimes i want
to sort
a list in decreasing order of the value
of integers
so what all can i do think about it one
thing that i can do is i can write
two sort functions the first sort
function to sort
in increasing order and another sort
function to sort in decreasing order
but if we will do so there will be a lot
of duplicate code
the two functions will be same except
just one character this less than sign
or greater than sign
writing duplicate code has a lot of
disadvantages
so can we do something better another
thing that we can do is we can pass
one more parameter to the sort function
to say whether we want the list sorted
in
increasing order or decreasing order we
can have a flag
let's say when flag is 1 we will sort in
increasing order and
when flag is zero we will sort in
decreasing order
using this approach we can avoid writing
a lot of duplicate code
what i'm going to do is i'm going to use
a function pointer
sorting of a list is always done on
basis of some ranking mechanism
so based on some property we should be
able to compare elements and say that
this should come first and this should
come later the core logic in sorting
will always be the same
only the ranking mechanism or comparison
logic will change
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
decide which element
is greater in rank and which element is
lesser
through a function basically i will
perform this comparison through a
function
my function will take a function pointer
as argument
my sort function will take function
pointer as argument
the callback function or the function
that this pointer should point to
must take two integers as argument
it should compare the two integers and
then it should
return back an integer it should return
1 if first element has higher rank
0 if the elements are equal and minus 1
if second element or second argument
has higher rank and let's say the
element that has higher rank
will go towards the end in sorted array
towards higher indices
these are my assumptions while designing
this sort function
now i am going to use my callback
function for comparison
if aj and aj plus 1 are now passed as
arguments to this callback function
and we get 1 so this condition will be
true
we will swap in this condition because
aj will have to be higher in rank
for this comparison function to return
one
so we will try to push aj towards higher
indices
let's now try to use this particular
implementation of bubble sort
i will have to write a callback function
first i have written a function like
this
now in main i can just use the name of
this function that will
return me a function pointer and pass it
in this call to bubble sort in this
comparison function
i have not written a statement to return
0 if elements are equal
equality doesn't matter in the logic so
for equality also i will
return -1 let's first
run this program and see the output this
is what i'm getting the numbers are
sorted in
increasing order now i will change the
comparison logic a bit
i will return minus 1 if a is greater
than b
so basically i have changed the ranking
mechanism
the element with lower value is now
ranked higher
and will go towards the end of the array
this is what i'm getting upon running
the program
the array is now sorted in decreasing
order of the value of integers
this is a really good design because now
our sort function can sort
a list of integers based on any ranking
mechanism
we can have one callback function for
each ranking mechanism
i will take one more example let's say
we have a list of integers with
both positive and negative values in it
i have modified a here a now has both
positive and
negative values this time i want to sort
this
array a in increasing order of the
absolute value of integers
so the negative sign will not matter we
will just take
a mod and then compare this
array a upon sorting should rearrange
like
this to be able to sort i will have to
write a comparison function
last time we had modified the same
compare function
but actually we should be writing one
comparison function for each sorting
scenario
so i will write a new function this time
i will write a function name
named absolute compare i have included a
reference to math.h library and i will
use
abs function from this library that will
give me absolute value of an integer
if absolute value of a is greater than
absolute value of
b then it's ranked higher i should
return one
else i should return minus one let's now
use this function to sort this
array i have a minor spell error here
okay instead of passing this compare
function i will now pass
absolute compare in this call to bubble
sort
this basically is passing a pointer to
absolute compare function
let's now run this program and see what
happens this is what i'm getting the
elements are sorted
in increasing order of their absolute
values the bubble sort function here
can take only an array of integers
but we have a library function that can
take
any array so it's further generic
this library function is in std
lib dot h library and it's named
q sort q sort for quick sort and to this
function you should pass
an array and it can be any array it can
be an array of integers or it can be
an array of characters or even a complex
data type
a structure first argument will be the
array second argument will be number of
elements in array
third argument will be size of the data
type
so if this is an array of integers i
need to pass
size of int size of data type in bytes
size of function gifs size of any data
type in
bytes last argument should be a function
pointer a pointer to compare
comparison function signature of the
comparison function should be like this
it should take two constant void
pointers as argument
and return an integer why word pointers
void pointers are generic pointers we
can type cast
them to a pointer of any data type
this is the specification of queue sort
function it should be passed a pointer
to such a function
so it will be able to call it back let's
write the comparison function
you can think of this as a reference of
first element
passed as a void pointer to get the
element
if it's a list of integers i'll first
have to
type cast the void pointer to endpointer
and then i'll have to use the asterix
operator
to dereference and get the value we will
do the same to get the value of
second element this function must return
any positive integer if a is ranked
higher
a negative integer if a is ranked lower
and 0 if both are ranked same we can
simply
return a minus b and it will mean the
same if
a is higher in value a minus b will be
positive
and i'm trying to create a simple
comparison function here
that would rank an integer with higher
value as high so basically
this comparison function can be used to
sort the array in
increasing order of value of integers so
like i said returning positive value
means
a is ranked higher returning negative
value means
b is ranked higher with this comparison
function if i would simply pass this to
q sort and after the call to queue sort
print the value
in this array this is what i will get
as you can see the list is sorted in
increasing order of the value of
integers
if i will change this comparison
function to return b minus a
so element with lesser value integer
with lesser value
will be ranked higher the list will be
sorted in decreasing order of the value
of integers
and if i will use abstract absolute
value of a minus absolute value of b
this is what i will get remember in this
comparison function
the two elements to be compared are
being passed
through reference their addresses are
being passed
through a pointer the const keyword here
means
you cannot modify the address in this
pointer variable
we are having to use void pointer
because of generic design of q sort
function
remember q sort can sort any array not
just
an integer array it's just that you will
have to give the comparison logic
okay so we just discussed one of the use
cases of function
pointers this whole idea of call back
is used in a lot of interesting design
scenarios
one more thing where this concept of
callback makes our
life easier is something called event
handling
if you are curious you can check the
description of this video
for some resources on event handling
this is
it for this lesson thanks for watching
in our previous lessons we have learnt
the concept of dynamic memory allocation
we have understood what is stack and
what is heap
in applications memory now in this
lesson we are going to talk about one
situation which is
caused by improper use of dynamic memory
or the memory on the heap and this
situation is memory leak
a quick recap of some of the concepts
that we have discussed in our previous
lessons
the memory that is allocated for the
execution of an
of a program or what we can also call
applications memory is typically
divided into these four segments or
these four sections
one section stores the instructions in
the program
that need to be executed this section is
called the code segment or the text
segment another section is used to store
the global variables the variables that
are not
declared inside functions and have
lifetime of the whole application
another section of the memory is used to
execute the function calls
and store all the local variables this
section is called stack
the size of these three segments the
code segment the global variable segment
and the stack segment
are fixed and decided when the program
is compiling
that is at the compile time and the
fourth section
which is called heap or dynamic memory
does not have a fixed size heap can grow
as per our need as we know we get memory
from the heap
by making a call to malloc function in c
and when we are done using that memory
on the heap we
make a call to the free function to
deallocate or free that particular
memory
in c plus apart from malloc and free we
can also use
the operator new to get some memory and
the operator delete
to free that memory memory leak is a
situation when we
get some memory on the heap and do not
free
it when we are done using it so our
application
is actually holding on to some unused
memory on the heap
but why do we call this situation memory
leak and why does it happen
due to improper use of dynamic memory
only
due to improper use of heap only and not
some other sections of applications
memory
we will try to understand this through
one simple program so what i'll do is
i'll write one simple program and show
the simulation of its execution in the
memory
to explain these concepts in my c
program here i'm going to write a very
simple betting game
and the game is that we have three
positions and three cards
jack queen and king initially jack is at
the first position
queen is at the second position and king
is at the third position
and then computer shuffles these cards
so that the positions of these cards
is changed is randomized and now the
player has to guess the position
of the queen he has to bet some amount
of money let's say it's virtual cash
and if he wins if he predicts the
position if he guesses the position of
queen correctly
he takes away three times the amount
that he had bet
and if he loses he simply loses the bet
amount
let's say the player initially has 100
of virtual cash
and he can play as many times as he
wants
until he runs out of cash so let us now
implement this game
the first thing that i want to do is i
want to declare a global variable
named cash that at any point will store
the
virtual cash available with the player
initially he has
100 of virtual cash and then in the main
method i will declare a variable named
bet and i will write code something like
this
while cash is greater than zero while
player still has some cash
we will ask him to bet something and we
will take this
input in this variable bet using
scanf uh for negative scenarios like bet
equals zero or
bet being greater than the cache
available let's say we will break out of
this loop we will end our game
for all other conditions let's say we
will make a call to play function
and of course now we will have to write
the play function
we will be passing bet to the play
function so
that will be an argument and now in the
play function i will declare
a character array of size 3 and
initially
we will have the character j at the
first position to say that
there is a jack at the first position j
is for jack and similarly
q is for queen and k is for king and now
the computer must perform a randomized
shuffling so we will write a print
statement like this now we need to find
a logic to make a random shuffle of
cards
one such logic is that we can make a
call to random number generator function
in c
to use the random number generator first
we will make a call to s
rand function and pass it an argument
something like this
i'll come back to what i'm doing here in
s rand by making a call to strand
now let's say we run a loop five times
and we will
choose any two random positions among 0
1
and 2 and swap the letters at these
positions in the array
let's say these positions are x and y
now when we make a call to rand function
we will get a random number
but we want a number between 0 and 2 0
and 2 included
so we will take a modulo by 3 so that we
either get 0
or 1 or 2. so we will take two such
random positions
with statements like this and now
what we can do is we can swap the
characters at these positions
so we will use a temporary variable
first we will store the character at
position
x in temp and then we will do
something like this i'm short of space
here so i'm writing three
statements in the same line okay so now
the swapping is done
so we are swapping or shuffling
uh characters at two positions five
times each time we are picking up two
positions
x and y randomly by making call to rand
function and taking a modulo by 3
so this will guarantee us that x and y
is between 0
and 2 that will be valid positions
by making a call to rand function we
will get the
random numbers but we also use this s
rand once and pass this
time null the return of
time function in random number
generation
there is something there is one concept
of seeding
uh the random number generator so we are
passing seed to random number generator
we will not go into the details of
random number generation now
now what i'll do in the play function is
i'll have a variable
uh named players guess and
i'll ask the player to guess the
position of queen
and then i will use scanf to take the
input
now if the player is correct then the
character at that particular position
in the character at a c and the position
will be
one minus what the player inputs
because the player is inputting one two
or three that will map to zero one and
two in the array
so if the character is queen he has one
so his overall cash will be incremented
by three times the bet amount
elsie has lost lost and his cash will be
decremented by the bit amount
so in the case of win we will write a
print statement like this
we will say that you have one and the
result is this and your total cash
right now is this remember cash is a
global variable
and we will print something similar if
the player loses
finally our play function is looking
something like this
and we have also moved this variable
cache at the top
in the main method i've added two more
print statements initially
now let's now play this game and see
what happens what i have done
is i have compiled this code and created
an executable
named game.exe and now i'm going to run
that executable
so this is asking what's your bet let's
say we want to bet
five dollars on position one
and i lose my balance now is 95 dollars
let's bet again this time again i lose
and i can go on playing so i'm losing
again and again
uh finally a win after long time uh i
can go on playing this game but i want
to show you something else
i have opened the task manager of
windows
and here as you can see this highlighted
row
is for game.exe the third column here is
the memory consumed by this
executable game.exe you will have to
see this in full screen now as i go on
playing
the memory consumption here the memory
that's showing here
it's not increasing it's always 348k
now i'll go ahead and make some changes
in my code what i'll do here is
this particular character array that i'm
creating as a local variable in the play
function
right now it's created as a local
variable
so it will go on the stack now i want to
create a character array on the heap
so what i'll do is i'll write statement
like this
i'll declare a character pointer named c
and then i'll use malloc to fetch memory
uh to store three character variables
in c plus plus we could have said
something like this we could have used
the new operator
and now i'll set value at z
zeroth index as j one at index as q and
two with index as
k so we have created uh an array on the
heap and c is a pointer
to the base address of that array c is
still a local variable but now it is a
pointer to character and we can still
use it like array rest of the code will
just work fine let us run this code and
see what happens
i have opened the task manager and i'm
running the executable
watch for the memory consumption of
game.exe
i will make some bets
as you can see right now the memory
consumption is 348k
i just kept on playing and after some
time the memory consumption is 488k
it has shot up and if you will keep
playing this game further
after some time it will shoot up again
maybe after some time but it will shoot
up for sure
so why is it happening why was it not
shooting up when see
the character array was not on the stack
not on the heap and it was on the stack
let's try to understand i have drawn
sections of applications memory here
and let us now see what really happens
in the memory
when we are playing our game as we know
from our previous lessons
all the information about function call
execution goes into
the stack section of the memory anytime
a function is called
some amount of memory from the stack is
allocated for its execution
when the program starts executing first
the main method is invoked or called
so let's say some amount of memory is
allocated for the execution of
main this is what we call the stack
frame of the function
so this is stack frame of main and all
the local variables of main
will sit inside this stack frame in our
code we had a local variable named bet
so it will go here and we had a global
variable named cache
so initially let's say main function is
executing
when we play our game main function
makes multiple calls to play function
what really happens when a function
makes call to another function is that
that particular function is paused and
memory is allocated for the execution of
the called function so main will pause
and play will start executing and play
will go on top of
main in the stack now we had a couple of
local variables in play all will go in
this stack frame
i x y players guess and
for the case one when we had the
character array c
on the stack itself so it was not
created using
a call to malloc the character array c
will also sit in this stack frame
now when the execution of play function
will finish control will return back to
main and the memory that was allocated
for the execution of play function will
be reclaimed
anytime a function call finishes the
memory that it is allocated on the stack
is reclaimed
so there is one stack frame
corresponding to each call
and as soon as that call finishes that
memory
is claimed back now main will make
another call to play because we will
play multiple rounds
so play will again come into the stack
and it will be cleared again when play
finishes
as you can see all the local variables
get cleared each time the function call
finishes
for anything on the stack we do not have
to worry about its d
allocation it happens automatically when
the function call finishes
now let's talk about the second case
when character array is created on the
heap using a call to malloc function
once again we will make multiple calls
to play function now what will happen
this time
is that we will not create the array on
the stack
we will still have a variable named c a
local variable named c
but this variable will not be of type
character array of size 3.
this variable will be of type pointer to
character and we will make a call to
malloc function to create the array on
the heap
and this local variable which is a
pointer to character will only point to
this particular memory block
anything that is on the heap has to be
accessed through a pointer variable
so here we have created the array on the
heap and we have kept only a pointer
variable on the stack
now when the call to play function will
finish the memory
allocated for the execution of call to
play function
will be reclaimed so all the local
variables will go away
but this memory on the heap will lie
unused and unreferenced
and it will not get deallocated anything
on the heap has to be explicitly
deallocated by making a call to free
function
or by using delete operator and think
about it we will make multiple calls to
play function
as we play multiple rounds of our game
and
each time in each call to play we will
create one such memory block on the heap
that will lie unreferenced and unused
when call to play function will finish
if we will play our game hundred rounds
then we will have hundreds such
unreferenced and
unused memory blocks of three characters
in the heap
heap is not fixed in size and our
application can
claim can get more memory in the heap
section
as long as our system itself is not
running out of memory and if we are not
deallocating
this unused memory on the heap we are
depleting and
wasting memory which is an important
resource our application's memory
consumption will only keep on growing
with time memory leaks are really nasty
bugs to have in your program
anything unused and unreferenced on the
heap is
garbage in c or c plus plus we have to
make sure as programmers
that garbage is not created on the heap
memory leak is nothing but growth of
garbage in the heap
in languages like java and c-sharp
garbage is automatically cleared from
the heap
so programmer does not have to worry
about freeing or deallocating the memory
on heap
which is a cool feature to have it
avoids memory leak
in this example we were creating an
array of three characters on the heap
what if we were creating an array of ten
thousand characters
and not freeing freeing the memory after
we were done using it
at the end of the function the memory
consumption would have shot up like
anything
coming back to my code here what i have
done is
i have created a character array of size
ten thousand
of ten thousand characters here uh my
logic would not change
i'll just use first three positions in
the array
i'm just trying to show you something
and at the end of this particular
function when we are done using this
array
on the heap we are making a call to the
free function
passing it the address of this memory
block this rac
our program will just work like before
but let's run this and monitor the
memory consumption once again
uh once again i'm showing you the task
manager and i'm playing the game
let's make some bets now watch out the
memory consumption of game.exe
for however long you will play the game
the memory consumption won't shoot up as
you can see it's
356 k and it's not shooting up for me
even after playing for a long time
and it is not shooting up because we had
used
free uh to deallocate
the memory when we were done using it at
the end of the function
remember we had created an array of size
10 000
and if we were not using free then the
memory would have
shot up like anything the memory
consumption would have shot up like
anything
but because we are freeing at the end of
the function it's not going up there is
no memory leak so finally to summarize
it
memory leak is improper use of dynamic
memory or the heap section of memory
that causes the memory consumption of
our program
to increase over a period of time
remember memory leak always happens
because of unused and unreferenced
memory blocks in the heap
anything on the stack is deallocated
automatically and stack is always fixed
in size
at the most we can have an overflow in
stack
so this was memory leak in cc plus
thanks for watching